[Musique]
christian harbulot bonsoir bonsoir nous
vous recevons pour une chaîne interne et
qui s'appelle singer view nous sommes en
direct est-ce que vous pouvez vous
présenter succinctement
je suis né à verdun ya bien longtemps
donc je fais alors un pur souche disons
d'une mère italienne et d'un père qui
venait d'un milieu assez pauvre et a
commencé à travailler à présent et je
crois que j'ai eu une histoire assez
atypique dans ma vie non paraître est en
fait si je devais la résumer cette vie
c'est une vie de combat avec un s à ces
différents finalement mais avec quand
même une ligne continue qui traverse
tout ça c'est l'aventuré humaine ou du
moins ce que j'espère avoir comme
aventure humaine
professionnellement parlant on fait quoi
alors je dirige une école qui s'appelle
école de guerre économique et à paris et
puis je fais aussi du conseil j'ai
contribué à créer avec des anciens
élèves un cabinet qui s'appelle le spin
partners qui est à paris accueille à
montrouge maintenant pour être précis
donc j'ai en fait deux activités est la
principale et le jeu bien sûr le ton
colonel alors lieutenant-colonel ça
c'est ça a surpris beaucoup de monde
c'est parce qu'à un moment donné il
fallait donner
des cours et de faire des séminaires sur
l'intelligence économique en fait
l'état s'était adressé aux structures
officielles qui pouvait le faire mais
visiblement ça les a pas vraiment
intéressés donc j'ai été recruté sur ce
qu'on appelle un titre 9 c'est à dire un
peu en logique d expertise pour faire
ces séminaires qui ont duré sur deux
trois ans voilà donc c'est à ce titre là
que j'ai été d autant que l
aujourd'hui on va parler intelligence
économique on va parler guerre
économique on va parler renseignement va
par l'écologie dont a parlé de la chine
on commence par la chine est ce que la
chine a menti est ce que les français se
sont laissés berner est ce que les
services français se sont laissés berner
consciemment ou ce sens qu une bande
d'incapables
je pense que la chine nuit elle a menti
parce que elle n'avait pas le choix en
fait c'est à dire que faut bien replacé
le décor c'est c'est un régime
communiste qui apparaît en 49 qui est un
peu seul contre tous c'était déjà pas
très simple avec l'union soviétique à ce
moment là ça s'est vérifié au début des
années 60 quand il ya eu le schisme
entre l'urss et la chine et c'est un
pays qui
[Musique]
et qui a continuellement
construit sa politique dans une logique
justement de combat dans une logique où
le fusil guide la politique quelque part
le fusil au sens métaphorique du terme
pourquoi parce que
mao tsé toung il s'est affrontée d'abord
au système qui étaient en face
qui à un moment donné était représenté
par chiang kai shek mais c'était pas
vraiment un ami de staline parce qu'il
avait une stratégie qui n'était pas la
même que celle que les soviétiques
voulaient appliquer en chine donc qu' il
était finalement assez isolé et de toute
une partie de sa vie c'était comment
s'en sortir comment ne pas disparaître
en fait et cette espèce da dn la danse
qu'est devenu le parti communiste
chinois
ça a été vraiment une greffe très très
forte dans la matrice marque risque
clinique si on appelle ça comme ça et ce
qui fait que quand il ya eu cette
histoire de qu'ovide
faut pas oublier que ce régime il a
encore un objectif simple c'est de
renverser le capitalisme je crois que
c'est dans l'adn d'un régime communiste
régime communiste il est pas là pour
faire élire des gens
organiser des petits déjeuners pour
plaider je ne sais quel modèle il est là
pour un objectif précis et quand on a un
objectif comme ça on sait ce qui est en
face on sait ce qu'on risque on sait ce
à quoi on s'expose donc sarah j c'est un
régime qui est en situation de guerre
non dites permanentes très différent du
cas des israéliens mais c'est quand même
une situation de guerre latente donc
admettre officiellement qu'ils étaient à
l'origine
de cette pandémie
c'était ouvrir la porte à tout ce qu'ils
avaient en face et qui allait bien
entretenu et exploiter ce chemin là
donc c'est la 2 pour moi la main la
dynamique du mensonge il commence comme
ça et c'est vrai que c'est un c'est un
vrai piège parce que
quand on se met à mentir et que petit à
petit on menti sur coup
ils ont menti sur sur la manière disons
dont les choses ont pu apparaître je
pense qu'il ya un problème dans le
calendrier dans dans la manière de gérer
l'émergence de l'information
et je crois qu'ils ont essayé
tant bien que mal bien entendu de
contenir et puis après de se donner les
moyens d'un régime capable de serrer la
vis partout pour éviter le pire mais
entre guillemets le problème était là
donc après c'était
un rétropédalage pas simple pour
tromper un peu l'adversaire c'est ce qui
s'est passé en recourant aux différents
moyens et essayer à tout prix de
maintenir l'image
qui s'était construit au fil des
décennies parce que c'est pas fait en
deux secondes rappelez-vous la la
prestation de jean ping à davos il n'y a
pas si longtemps que ça qu'ils disent
est en fait moi je suis pour la
mondialisation je défends le libre
échange et quelque part je suis plus
honnête que donald trump pour faire ce
genre de chose bon donc j'ai un
commentaire de la communauté on dirait
qu'il marie de nombreux journalistes et
ou observateur ou élus étaient présents
à one la chine a été sous étroite
surveillance où sont les preuves que la
chine ne
s'est pas tellement le problème du
mensonge
encore une fois je crois qu'on peut ne
le comprendre que si on remet tout ça
dans le rapport de force c'est à dire
j'insiste le régime communiste chinois
ne peut pas apparaître comme faible par
rapport aux pays qui est son adversaire
principal
les états unis avant tous les autres
bien sûr donc la moindre faille qui peut
laisser penser à une défaillance
encore effectivement après faut-il
remonter la chaîne d'information pour
savoir ce qui s'est passé c'est
obligatoirement quelque chose qui risque
de les affaiblir ou de les déranger mais
là en l'occurrence on voit bien comment
le feu a pris dans la plaine c'est à
dire que si
un certain nombre de pays à travers le
monde se sentent touchés
- par les faits le volume de l'épidémie
mais plus par le choc économique qui en
retour et ce qui va apparaître
éventuellement par la suite
le rétropédalage continuer à fonctionner
puisqu'il ya des gens qui qui vont quand
même essayer de comprendre pourquoi ils
en sont là et c'est pas ce qu'ils vont
se retrouver au chômage c'est pas ce
qu'ils vont se retrouver dans la misère
parce qu'ils ont d'autres chats à
fouetter entre guillemets mais c'est un
système de compréhension du monde face à
un autre est en fait ce qu'on ce à quoi
on assiste depuis pas mal de temps c'est
la confrontation entre ces deux systèmes
une autre question de la communauté
pourquoi les services sont-ils besoin d
informations par la chine
on a personne sur place
ah ça c'est la grande question
c'est la grande question
faire de l'espionnage en chine pour un
pays occidental
c'est pas simple c'est pas simple parce
que on est quand même devant un pays
la france un certain complexe par
rapport à la chine souvenez vous l'un
d'eux chine
c'est la chine communiste qui à partir
de 49 permet aux vietminhs de s'armer
mais plus que ça dien ben phu sans la
chine sans l'aide logistique mais
peut-être un peu plus d'ailleurs que
l'aide logistique
c'est pas forcément la même issue bon ça
veut dire qu'on a déjà cette espèce de
complexe je me souviens qu'un d'avoir lu
dans des livres dits sérieux que
les français aiment en 2d choper
les membres d'un état-major d'une
division chinoise qui avait traversé la
frontière et qu'ils étaient donc sur le
sol indochinois ça aurait pu être un
argument de propagande pour dire il ya
eu une intrusion
ce pays se mêle de ce qui ne le regarde
pas et sait mais on l'a pas exploité
cette affaire là on n'a pas exploité
parce qu'on était déjà pieds poings liés
dans une sorte de complexe de puissance
c'est à dire que
on avait les américains d'un côté on
avait
cette réalité indochinoise qui n'était
pas évidente on aurait mieux fait pas la
faire cette guerre d'indochine et de
données indépendance assez vite comme
certains au début comme leclerc ou
d'autres l'avait
souhaité ou indiqué mais en tout cas
très vite on n'a pas su je dirais relevé
la tête en fait donc pourquoi je vous
dis ça par rapport à la guerre
d'indochine c'est qu'un plant et des
agents français sur territoire chinois
qui ne soient pas des gens de
l'ambassade mais qu'ils soient des gens
qui peuvent travailler pour les services
français comme ça arrive c'est souvent
c'est à dire qu'ils ne soient pas des
agents tant que tel mais qu'ils soient
des gens qui travaillent les entreprises
etc
il ya un vrai risque et et c'est un
risque très très dur une anecdote une
anecdote qui résume un peu comment ça se
passe là bas je me souviens des années
90 lorsque j'étais à défense conseil
international
on avait croisé un cadre expatrié d'une
firme multinationale qui était française
d'origine et en chine et ce cadre nous
expliquer ce qui lui était arrivé en
fait il lui était arrivée il ya une
chose assez intéressante c'est à dire
que
il s'est senti tout de suite sous
surveillance bien sûr et un moment donné
il a été convoqué et par une autoroute
une autorité chinoise qui lui a dit
écoutez on enquête sur vous
il ya un problème je peux pas vous dire
quel est le problème mais sachez que
voilà vous êtes
sous notre surveillance très très
accentué parce que c'est une enquête et
quelques mois plus tard le même individu
le ramène 20 lui dit de revenir et nous
dit va écouter
faut que je vous dise on n'a rien contre
vous parce qu'en fait on s'est rendu
compte que c'est un de vos compatriotes
qui vous a balancé pour vous
déranger dans votre boulot ici chez
alors c'est une anecdote tout à fait
véridique un qui est intéressante parce
que ça montre à la fois système de
surveillance qui n'est pas simplement
suivre les allées et venues serre c'est
une vraie surveillance comme on peut le
faire penser certains régimes avant la
guerre fin pardon avant la chute du mur
mais en plus de ça il ya ce talent entre
guillemets qui est de le discernement
c'est à dire de gérer les contradictions
et d'en profiter si l'autre est en
contradiction et ben j'utilise cette
contradiction et je vais l'affaiblir où
je vais avoir
un avantage sur lui psychologique la
suite et la chine c'est ça c'est à dire
c'est donc j'en viens à la question
implanter un réseau d'espionnage pour la
france en chine qui ne soit pas dans
l'ambassade est protégée par le statut
diplomatique
c'est une pas une mince affaire c'est
vraiment très compliqué et c'est très
compliqué pourquoi parce que
si je fais une comparaison si j'ose une
comparaison
une des grosses affaires d'espionnage
économique menés par la france dans les
années 80 c'est aux états unis ça a fini
par sortir un journaliste de l'express
qui a fait
de longs papiers pour expliquer cette
affaire donc il y avait une volonté à
l'époque
je crois que ça à l'époque de pierre
marion quand il a appris la dgse qui
étaient devenus des gse après s'être
appelée ce dec et il y avait donc une
opération dans l'industrie informatique
américaine sur un certain nombre de
firmes et la pratique française là
c'était d'aller au contact de cadres qui
étaient dans ces firmes d'enfer en fait
des non pas simplement des honorables
correspondants mais des gens qui
espionnait pour la france parce qu'il y
avait un véritable enjeu là pour une
fois on il faisait pas
n'importe quoi il faisait brut il et
puis finalement ça s'est très mal
terminée il y avait plusieurs dizaines
de personnes selon les dires du
journaliste de l'express qui était un
type sérieux qui étaient impliqués dans
cette affaire et visiblement il ya
quelqu un ailleurs qui a eu des états
d'âme on espionne pas un allié etc enfin
bref l'information a fuité on n'a jamais
su trop comment on n'a jamais su s'il y
avait eu sanction ou pas d'ailleurs et
mais c'était possible et ce que je veux
dire c'est à dire que à cette époque-là
années 80 les services de renseignement
français avaient encore les capacités de
gérer un certain nombre de personnes
travaillant dans un pays du type états
unis pour eux la même chose en chine
le scénario va être complètement
différent si ça se passe mal je ne suis
pas sûr que ce soit une crise
diplomatique passagère après une réunion
de compromis les américains qui tape
très fort sur la table le fait que
depuis cet événement là je ne suis pas
certain que le renseignement économique
au sein de des gse et était une des
tâches prioritaires de ce service etc
alors imaginez en chine ce qui se
passerait en chine d'abord je suis pas
certain qu'on reverrait certains cadres
d'une part il pourrait avoir quelques
problèmes de santé pas forcément que
vite d'ailleurs et
et quelle est la marge de négociation
comment on négocie avec un pays pareil
pour négocier avec un pays pareil il
faut être méchant
faut être capable de rentrer dans les
contradictions leurs contradictions
leurs contradictions
si je prends un exemple on ce qui se
passe à hong kong
on voit bien qu'à hong kong il ya eu
deux séquences qui sont très
intéressantes une première où il ya eu
une tentative de entre guillemets de ce
que j'appellerais une révolution que
leur revu et corrigé c'est à dire une
partie de la population congrès cam la
démocratie se méfie
de du rattachement la chine et des
conséquences puisque tôt ou tard ce
rattachement qui est prévu dans le cadre
de l'accord signé avec la grande
bretagne il aura lieu donc hong kong va
devenir un territoire réellement chinois
il n'est pas encore tout à fait et puis
ça s'est calmé cette histoire parce que
bon il ya eu les moyens pour calmer
l'histoire enfin c'était pas des moyens
forcément sympathique on s'en doute
et puis il ya eu la deuxième
entre guillemets
révolte celle qui s'est déroulée l'année
dernière est où là
on voyait bien c'était compliqué pour le
régime chinois de contenir ce qui était
en train de se passer là-bas
c'était compliqué par les techniques
classiques de rappeler suppression du
genre tiananmen c'est à dire c'est un
autre cadre et
là
j'ai du mal à croire que c'est
simplement de gentils citoyens chinois
qui se révoltent c'est pas si simple on
a on a quand même une simulation de rien
bas et je pense qu'il n'est pas
impensable et ça serait logique que y
ait des gens qui appuient là où ça fait
mal
petit flashback et on viendra ensuite
aux français
durant
la période lech walesa solidarnosc la
pologne
l'a effectivement moi j'ai eu la chance
de de travail et de créer l'école de
guerre avec un général cette lépi
chaduteaud et qui était attaché de
défense à varsovie
et qui était un type qui avait une
certaine passion justement
cet homme là
sans trahir de secret d'état
un attaché de défense théoriquement à
l'époque et encore aujourd'hui ne doit
pas faire de renseignement d'accord dans
le système actuel français mais pichot
duclos avait une passion c'est quelqu'un
qui s'intéressait à ce qui se passait et
donc le mouvement solidarnosc bien sûr
qu'il ya eu un un côté populaire dans
cette histoire enfin il a bien fallu des
dockers qui commence à se mettre en
grève etc mais on a bien vu que derrière
ça dans les soutiens dans dans ce qui
est arrivé d'europe voire au delà de
l'europe il n'y avait pas que des
gentils citoyens la main sur le coeur
qu'ils étaient pour le soutien de celui
d'un c'était beaucoup plus compliqué
donc ce que je veux ce que j'entends par
là c'est que quand on étudie un peu le
cheminement des techniques d'inférence
des techniques de guerre d'information
des moyens mis en place oui une
évolution dans le monde occidental et
c'est vrai que les américains ont
on tirait que je crois un certain nombre
de leçons de périodes où ils ont été
beaucoup moins performant d'ailleurs je
pense en particulier au vietnam et
ça les a rendues plus efficaces ils ont
intégré pas mal de choses
nous
on n'est pas dans cet univers là enfin
je veux dire bien sûr
je dis pas qu'on a été nuls sur ces
questions là il ya eu des expériences
françaises assez étonnante même au
moment de la guerre d'indochine il y en
a une qui est relaté dans une thèse
d'histoire qui a été mise en ligne hier
sur le site à l'époque du ministère de
la défense devenu ministère des armées
excellent livre sur l'histoire des
services secrets français en indochine
et qui montre qu'il y avait sur le
territoire de chinois une petite équipe
de civils qui écoutait et qui était
assez bien cachés d'ailleurs sans aucune
protection militaire il ya même ceux
relatés dans la thèse un général de
l'époque qui avait écrit une note de
protestation en disant mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cette bande là de gens
ils sont pas encadrées protéger enfin
qu'est ce que c'est que ces histoires en
fait c'est des gens qui ont été très
efficaces y ont été très efficaces parce
que justement 49 les renseignements
militaires français à écouter les
communications du vietminh et en attirer
beaucoup davantage et pourquoi on a été
efficace même si on n'avait pas
d'énormes moyens c'est parce que vous
connaissez nos faiblesses je parle du
renseignement militaire attention en
tant que c'est pas le sexe et les
renseignements militaires
voilà enfin c'est ce qui est devenu plus
tard bien plus tard l'adn et à l'époque
les gens appelons ça le deuxième bureau
même si ça avait une autre appellation
avait bien entendu des sources en
indochine locale
mais c'était une catastrophe parce que
c'était la plupart étaient des agents
doubles travailler pour le vietminh etc
mais ils le savaient et donc une très
très belle opération montée par les
services français à l'époque c'était
d'exploiter cette faiblesse c'est à dire
de faire un coup classique
il avait une transcription d'une écoute
le vietnam ne savait pas forcément
qu'ils étaient écoutées à ce point et il
laisse traîner la feuille sur la table
et un agent local donc viêt voix le
texte est sûre le texte il était dit que
il y avait un agent français entre
guillemets dans la direction du vietminh
donc ça ça a causé une pagaille forte ça
ça a déclenché une enquête intérieur qui
était pas anodine et ça c'est une belle
opération donc oui les français
ponctuellement comme ça ont réalisé des
choses assez intéressantes mais c'est
pas un système faut pas en conclure que
il ya une mémoire opérationnel on a
connu ça alors évidemment il y en a qui
vont tout de suite arrivés avec les
écrits de trinquier les écrits de galula
en disant oh mais ils ont perdu
trinquier canular je suis désolé hier le
gc et marne indochine ok il ya eu des
choses intéressantes fête dans les
tribunes mais oh mais on on a perdu
enfin ma connaissance on n'a pas gagné
en indochine et en algérie
c'est un peu la même chose c'est-à-dire
cuit il ya eu des opérations
intéressantes notamment par
un capitaine restée célèbre sur la fée
le capitaine léger sur la sphère de la
bleuite
opération redoutable mais est un auteur
américain qui a écrit un très très bon
livre sur comment la france a mené la
guerre de l'information
dans le cas de l'algérie d'accord et il
précise bien que on a eu une défaite
stratégique à une victoire tactique et
le problème c'est que d'abord faut
différencier les choses le stratégie que
c'est quoi pour imager ça l'américain
explique que dans les coulisses des
nations-unies
les jeunes du fln en costume cravate
qui était courtisé d'ailleurs un peu par
nos amis américains ne faut pas
l'oublier qui avait accès certains
couloirs de la maison blanche soit au
début de la présidence kennedy
d'ailleurs et même un peu avant ces gens
là ils représentaient le progrès vers le
fln
c'était pas une bande de barbares sortie
du bled dans une katiba c'était des
types costume cravate et c est là qu lax
de guerre de l'information de l'état
français à l'époque c'est nous apportons
progrès contre des barbares donc déjà il
ya un problème est un problème de
scénario il ya un problème de casting
entre guillemets et ces choses là je
suis pas sûr qu'on les ait bien c'est un
américain qui raconte ça c'est pas un
français et on n'a pas filtré on n'a pas
fait la part des choses et moi je me
suis quand même a posteriori rendu
compte d'une chose qui est hyper
importante c'est qu'hier fils bilan ça
parce que la fin de la guerre d'algérie
ça se termine mal il ya la tentative de
putsch d'alger après ios etc il ya en
plus cerise sur le gâteau beaucoup de
ces gens là qui était pas forcément
pour ce que le goal était en train de
faire donc donc entre la fin de la
guerre d'algérie
jusqu'à la fin des années
90 il n'était pas
de bon ton d'écrire un article là dessus
dans des revues lié au ministère de la
défense français parce que c'était
l'omerta c'était on a refermé le livre
on a pu voulu entendre parler de ça donc
ça a créé une coupure et une coupure
importante et ce qui reste de sa basse
et délivre question la communauté est ce
qu'on peut encore qualifier le régime
chinois de communistes au vu de sa
politique économique
ça c'est une question hyper intéressante
pourquoi parce que n'oublions pas encore
une fois l'histoire à la sortie de la
guerre civile russe et à quelque chose
qui s'appelle la nouvelle économie
politique
parce que la russie bolchévique
était exergue et elle a demandé l'aide
occidentale en fait et là on a vu
arriver en russie d des entreprises
américaines de l'argent européen etc et
si on allait en russie alors ça n'a pas
duré très longtemps on est d'accord mais
si on allait en russie à ce moment là
passer de la guerre civile russe la
nouvelle économie politique avec
l'ouverture sur une aide occidentale
c'est pas simple à comprendre déjà à ce
moment là mais c'était une tactique
russe il avait besoin du monde
occidental pour pour éviter la
catastrophe dont qu'ils ont très
habilement à ce moment-là jouer sur
cette aide est en face on penser que le
régime a laissé couler et que bon bah on
était déjà et on était là avant les
autres vous connaissez la musique avec
les chinois
c'est un peu la même chose c'est à dire
que c'est pas parce qu'on nous a raconté
qui a eu la bande des cadres que ça
s'est mal terminée qui est arrivé un
réformateur qui s'appelle monsieur tenza
au ping et que à partir de là en
parallèle à cause du schisme sino
soviétique finalement
la chine communiste s'est rapproché du
monde occidental
ça c'est comme on dit pas chez nous mais
un storytelling qui correspond pas à la
réalité la réalité c'est quoi c'est que
le régime communiste chinois qui bien
sûr à une évolution compliqué avec des
échecs très lourd je pas revenir sur
l'échec du grand bond en avant sur
l'échec de la révolution des cent fleurs
sur les pertes humaines liées à ça mais
qu'ils avaient à un poignard sous le
menton d'accord
donc ils vivaient ses pas pour l'excuser
j ça c'est le rapport de forces c'est la
réalité ok donc
c'est un régime qui a compris que
lorsque l'union soviétique était en
train de se faire piéger
par le monde occidental rappelez vous la
période reagan notamment lui il voulait
pas suivre le mot mais exactement donc
il a fallu intégrer l'effondrement de
l'union soviétique
la disparition du pacte de varsovie et
pour eux continuer à exister et là on
peut quand même se dire on va pas
continuer à exister en disant lorient et
rouge le pouvoir est au bout du fusil et
on va butter tous les capitalistes du
monde entier c'est fou est un peu plus
rusé que ça quand même il me semble donc
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait eh ben je
pense qu'ils ont réussi quelque chose
d'assez habile c'est à dire
de faire non pas une nouvelle économie
politique mais quand même il ya un ça y
ressemble mais à l'asiatique c'est à
dire que il avait très très bien
n'étudier comment un pays comme le japon
avait évité de se faire coloniser
en créant une économie et pas n'importe
comment pour en dire un mot plus tard
ils ont suivi sa d'assez près ils ont
compris que le japon
pour éviter la colonisation que eux
avaient subi sur leurs côtes
orientale rappelons-nous
les concessions faites les deux cars de
l'opium enfin avec ses directeurs pour
éviter ça
et bien
ils ont fait croire au monde occidental
que finalement ils allaient changer
et ça je trouve ça remarquable
remarquable pourquoi je peux me
permettre de dire ça dans mon petit vécu
à 3 centimes d'euros
parce qu'un jour j'ai une chance
je suis allé un petit colloque organisé
par une fac d'histoire à la roche sur
yon c'était au milieu des années 2000 et
je prends le train avec un des
intervenants il y avait deux chinois de
la chine communiste et celui qui était à
côté de moi dans le train
je m'étais un peu renseigné avant qui
c'était et comme j'avais appartenu à un
groupe défense conseil international
j'avais accès à certaines sources on m'a
dit tu sais et c'est l'équivalent du
patron de l'ifri donc si tu français des
relations internationales mais c'est pas
la même taille et il est fortement
soupçonné d'être le patron du sr
extérieur chinois europe bras
intéressant
surtout pour un ancien maïs comme moi
intéressant donc je commence à discuter
et c est là
deux images deux images
premières images
il plante décor je sais pas comment
c'est venu à une discussion il me dit
mais
nous on se souvient d'une chose vous
avez appris la langue écrite aux
vietnamiens
vous français et ça c'est pas possible
pourquoi parce que c'est aux marche de
notre pays autrement dit vous nous avait
empêchés de nous rapprocher du peuple
vietnamien parce que je crois que c'est
un jésuite avait créé cet angle écrite
qui n'existaient pas
deuxièmement pour le fan un moment donné
indiscrétions du dia vous savez il ya eu
les mains vis en france et c est là je
pense qu'il va regarder à peu près ça me
rappelle le film la grande vadrouille ou
un moment donné le tout début il ya un
officier allemand en tenue noire qui a
une chiure de pigeon sur son uniforme je
pense que j'avais à peu près cette
valeur là pour lui d'accord donc c'était
très instructif dans le rapport amical
de discussions entre peuples donc donc
j'ai compris à qui j'avais à faire mais
là où j'ai surtout compris à qui j'avais
affaire c'est qu'à la roche sur yon donc
à des interventions et c est après il ya
le débat et les interventions elle
portait sur quoi elle portait sur
les relations internationales et
notamment les relations etats unis chine
europe et un moment donné alors l'autre
chinoise précise c'est important c'est
quelqu'un qui est venait de l'académie
des sciences sociales de pékin d'accord
dans ce petit noyau très intéressant au
sein de cette académie des sciences
sociales de pékin et il faisait pas de
la poésie chinoise
et donc je sais
il était avec cet homme là et le chinois
qui m'avaient accompagné ou que j'avais
accompagné plutôt prend la parole et dit
et la cx faille
il faudrait qu'on saline ou
chinois et européens contre les
américains sur tel problème et il sort
une contradiction économique où les
américains sont en tort
et là je me dis ah là j'ai pas à faire à
n'importe qui on parlait de guerre de
l'information il est là dedans mais au
sens éléments de langage je trouve la
contradiction parce que je parle
beaucoup du mot contradictions
bien entendu le mot contradiction c'est
la bible du maoïsme
si mao tsé toung a appris quelque chose
oula transcrites de manière intelligente
temps à travers dû dépenser anciennes ou
plus récentes au niveau du martyr c'est
la contradiction principale et les
contradictions secondaires et la
contradiction principale c'est ce que
d'autres définir et peut-être comme pour
aller chercher le centre de gravité mais
c'est un élément essentiel et le chinois
à ce jour là à la roche-sur-yon il nous
sort une contradiction principale à
exploiter en guerre d'information en
suggérant une alliance entre européens
et chinois wahaha intéressant quand même
intéressant que quand vous analysez le
la communication de l'ambassade de chine
en france sur twitter
alors justement pour
bien mettre à plat les choses et
continuent à répondre à la question de
la personne
qu'il a posés par le net est ce que les
chinois sont encore communiste oui à une
matrice communiste de combat qui existe
toujours est ce qu'elle est partout dans
le système chinois je pense pas
je pense pas parce que justement autre
histoire personnelle au moment de la
crise des subprimes
je suis contacté juste avant par un
ancien ambassadeur de france
qui vit en chine et qui vit avec une
chinoise
et qui me fait passer le message disant
oui
les chinois connaissent l'école de
guerre économique à paris ça les
intéresse et il faut que vous les
rencontriez ils ont une proposition à
vous faire
ça met tout de suite à l'aise
donc à rendez-vous est pris là on est
déjà un peu dans dans quelque chose
d'assez drôle enfin faut prendre la vie
du bon côté
c'est un café voyez la rue qui est en
face de l'assemblée nationale il ya une
petite rue qui remonte et donc je dois
je suis planté là d'un antiquaire je
crois mettez-vous là on va venir vous
chercher
alors je vais demander à un ou deux
copains quand même de
devoir
l'ambiance quand il faisait beau
et arrive trois personnes et surprise
arrive le type avec qui j'avais fait le
voyage en train d'accord qui ressort
comme ça quand une tulipe à côté de lui
un type plutôt
apparatchiks du parti c'était un
ambassadeur itinérant et puis il n'alla
pas très drôle qui était la traductrice
de l'ambassade
alors on va dans un café et pendant une
heure chez l'ambassadeur a qui mène la
danse en fait ils débriefait des gens
comme ça
sur mais pourquoi il ya eu crise en
prime comment vous déchiffrer ce truc
quel est votre avis là-dessus et c'est
hélas là j'avais pas en face de moi un
cadre de combat communiste ayant cette
culture de combat communiste j'avais
plutôt un apparatchik pas très à l'aise
dans ses chaussures
parce que plus il parlait plus je me
disais mais attendez il ya une
communauté chinoise en france il
travaille en france ils ont des postes
qui sont pas n'importe où dans les
sociétés
pourquoi il les interroge pas sur leur
ressenti à eux parce que ce que je vais
leur raconter les autres pourraient au
moins leur dire au moins 80% la même
chose donc là j'ai quand même eu sous
les yeux deux mondes chinois le monde
combattant qui perdure à travers les
services et le monde des apparatchiks où
on est ailleurs on est dans dans une
autre forme d'existence avec d'autres
intérêts etc donc je pense que la chine
oui bien sûr qu'il ya encore une chine
communiste
le type de l'académie des sciences
sociales de pékin dont j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure il fait partie de ce noyau où on
pense à stratégie face aux états unis et
comment on va pas faire plier par le
système capitaliste est assez clair mais
ça représente quoi par rapport à 1
milliard 500 millions de chinois li lé
maximum donc c'est un petit groupe
finalement mais attention c'est un
groupe redoutable donc que oui bien sûr
qu'ils sont toujours commune revenons à
ma question comment vous analysez la
communication de l'ambassade chinoise en
france sur twitter
elle se veut fun et original
communications militaires empreinte de
toute la mémétique internet pour mieux
passer non oui mais oui mais alors avec
un problème je voulais ce pic dans un
autre exemple toujours c'est bien de
prendre ses ex ante personnel et à un
jour avec un la guerre économique ont
fait chaque année un examen de guerre de
l'information est toujours durant les
années 2000 c'est remonte déjà pas loin
de dix ans consiste aux coups bas en
gros on prépare cet exercice pendant un
mois un mois et demi avec un comité de
pilotage de 15 20 personnes ça dépend
des années et puis l'exercice à lire une
semelle et à tous une promo de ge ne
fait que ça pendant une semaine donc là
le le thème qui avait été choisi c'était
la chine conquérante au niveau
économique donc on avait créé un blog
qui s'appelait chine conquérante et sur
ce blogue qu'est ce qu'on avait fait
beau on avait d'abord regardé qu'est ce
qu'il y avait sur le net et on s'était
rendu compte ça nous avait pas étonné
mais conforté dans une certaine idée des
choses c'est que les anglo saxons
étaient virulents sur la sphère du tibet
sur la sphère de la place tiananmen sur
la sphère de la secte falun gong sur
éventuellement
le problème bien sûr de taïwan donc les
quatre gros dossiers où il y avait une
expression entre guillemets assimilé à
de la propagande de la gamme
d'informations venant notamment du monde
anglo saxon
mais bizarrement
rien sur mais comment les chinois
partent à la conquête du monde
économique en essayant nous piéger en
essayant de jouer sur nos contradictions
rien donc nous petite goutte d'eau dans
l'océan donc école de guerre économique
on met ce blog en ligne et on laisse
ouvert les commentaires parce que c'est
ça qui intéresse et là on voit arriver
qui
première vague de commentaires vous êtes
des racistes vous êtes anti chinois
enfin pas très habile de la première
vague de commentaires mais surtout ce
qui est intéressant qui sait qui parle
c'est des français qui il en chine c'est
pas des chinois
avec un faux profil ou je sais pas quoi
penser des français qui il en chine qui
disent non non vous moi je vis en chine
vous vous raconter des conneries en
ont contre
deuxième vague de commentaires
ça dure à peu près sur trois semaines un
mois
là ça commence un peu à s'affiner c'est
à dire il commence à aller nous chercher
sur
sur des problèmes de confrontation
économique
et surtout la troisième vague de
commentaires où là il tape nos
contradictions intra muros donc là j'ai
vu l'évolution j'ai vu l'évolution et
comme on les suit depuis un certain
temps de manière en dents de scie un je
suis pas chaque matin je me lève pas en
regardant la carte de la chine
mais c'est vrai que quand on avait
travaillé par exemple avant que pékin
obtienne
le fait d'être la ville pour organiser
les jeux olympiques rappelez vous
c'était en 2008 je crois on avait étudié
un peu les affrontements informationnel
dans ce cadre là aussi
et on s'était rendu compte que au début
il était très sûr le thème racisme anti
chinois première ligne quoi c'est à dire
assez arc boutés et puis
la taxe est émoussé parce qu'il y avait
des attaquants ou saxon il ya eu
d'autres types d' attaque mais
ils ont surtout eu un premier problème
rappelez vous c'est la caravane
itinérante de la flamme
et là ils ont raté complètement le coche
à il s'attendait pas aux manifs de
reporters sans frontières
l'ambassadeur chinois à paris a pris
plus qu'une relevé de bretelles ils font
pas trop dans la poésie au niveau des
bretelles sûrs et ce que je veux dire et
et là on a compris que une fois de plus
c'est un système vivant
comment apprend qu'il
est je note quand même une chose c'est
que oui ils tentent d'être moderne mais
à la différence des russes à la
différence des russes qui eux
je pense ont une véritable culture
très longue
pas que de la désinformation
j'irai de le
le fer de lance de la culture soviétique
c'est là la pénétration des systèmes
cognitifs occidentaux ces packs la
désinformation parce que ça ça touche
des vastes vastes couches les chinois
n'ont pas su faire ça les chinois n'ont
pas su faire ça pour des raisons assez
précises faut pas oublier que
le chinois
n'est pas dans la même posture culturel
d'un pâle la même manière de voir les
autres et c'est donc ce que je veux dire
par là c'est que le système de guerre de
l'information chinois en englobant
l'ensemble
il a des gens assez doué
mais à faible dose comme celui que j'ai
croisés qui était pas n'importe qui mais
il a aussi des trous énormes dans la
raquette c'est à dire les chinois ils
n'ont pas su faire aussi à tous dès les
six noah ils n'ont pas su faire spoutnik
oui mais regardez comment ils le font je
veux dire ça a peut-être évoluer mais au
début il copiait les américains c'est à
dire il faisait de la copie vas-tu faire
jazeera ni france 24 non et il faisait
de la copie il faisait de la copie un
peu en disant mais nous aussi on fait on
sait faire un studio télé nous aussi on
a une présentatrice qui parle comme là
bas nous mais il était plutôt dans ce
registre là en revanche
on voit bien aimé échanges notamment
avec un chinois qui est venu à le jeu
dans une formation continue qui
m'expliquait mais attention la
contradiction principale de la gare de
l'information chinoise c'est interne un
tenir le peuple n'ont pas forcément à la
schlague mais au niveau des enjeux
politiques dans la vie politique
chinoise 2 c les petites chine c'est la
chine de canton face à la chine de pékin
c'est les contradictions historique lié
à ça et 3 et ça ça vient bien après
c'est éventuellement
ce qui entoure la chine où ça se passe
pas si bien rappelez-vous le vietnam
mais même le vietnam aujourd'hui suite à
des différents enjeux et leucate c'est
un rapport au monde occidental est là le
problème sur le 4 c'est
comment on est malin quoi comment on est
malin et il ya eu pour prendre un
exemple vous voyez que la fondation de
la recherche stratégique qui est une
fondation
officielle française avec une référence
avec véronique et ses acquis
quand même pour une fois assez
assez offensive entre guillemets dans
ses analyses
la première action chinoise c'est
presque de les mettre en procès ac c'est
s'arquebouter c'est à dire que
aujourd'hui
leur problème
c'est qu'ils sont quand même sous le
coup du changement de ligne c'est à dire
tenza hopping c'est profil bas d'accord
excusez moi je vous met il pas remonté
l'intérêt c'est pas ce qui s'est un
petit peu vous triste sur la guerre en
irak non ça c'est une autre histoire
c'est notre référence pour moi ça veut
dire ouvrir c'est une autre histoire
c'est une autre histoire mais là là on
parle vraiment du cadereau chine
là je pense qu'il ya un côté assez
offensive dans l'analyse je parle pas de
la justesse ou non des annels jeudi la
posture quoi et mais avec des analyses
quand même intéressante
ce que je constate c'est que les chinois
sont arqueboutées
c'est à dire que ils ont du mal
aujourd'hui à sortir de la posture je me
justifie
au regard de l'information il faut
jamais se justifier quand on commence à
justifier on est mort
donc le problème qu'ils ont à mon avis
c'est
en changeant de lignes sous terre ça au
ping jusqu'à une période récente c'était
profil bas
et c'était plus simple
si on passe au profil haut et le profil
haut c'est
même moi je suis prêt à conquérir le
monde hein c'est un des deux auteurs de
la guerre hors limite le général en
retraite qui était colonel quand il a
écrit le bouquin il a donné une
interview il n'ya pas longtemps ou à la
fin il dit mais la chine peut dominer le
monde
là
bas on est un peu dans le plan
barbarossa chinois si je veux dire c'est
à dire que si on commence à dire je vais
dominer le monde bah le monde il vous
regarde
et il sourit enfin je vais pas faire un
mauvais jeu de mots mais jaune justement
est donc le vrai problème c'est que je
crois qu'ils n'ont pas pris la mesure
des logiques
d'encerclement être content simplement
en matière de guerre d'information c'est
à dire que pour des raisons qui sont
certainement lié
à l'histoire contemporaine chinoise aux
réalités internes du parti communiste
chinois he à la personnalité de jean
ping des gens qui l'entourent et c'est
le fait de passer dans le dans cette
stratégie du profil haut qui est de dire
nous ça nous fait pas peur de dominer le
monde et on n'est pas peur de le dire de
l'affirmer je pense qu' ils n'ont pas
compris qu'en faisant ça ils se priver
de toute une marge de manoeuvre de
guerre de l'information indirectes comme
on dit dans certains jargon où il vaut
mieux apparaître comme la victime où il
vaut mieux apparaître comme celui c'est
parce qu'ils sont en train de faire
quand ils font de la communication avec
des lego est prêt oui quand quand donald
trump le redis vandalisé les chinois
n'ont pas communiqué ils répondent avec
une vidéo virale très bien fait c'est
vrai on est en disant voilà on a très
bien communiquer tel jour telle date on
a comme unique et ainsi de suite c'est
vrai ça ça marche mais il manque sa
destination des peuples des six st on
est d'accord oui mais le problème
ils connaissent quoi de la chine des
français les français ils connaissent
déjà pas l'allemagne alors la chine
c'est loin je boycotte de leur
nom et vous voyez ce que je veux dire le
problème c'est qu'ils ils font une
guerre de l'information très
professionnel mais en partant du
principe que ceux qui vont la recevoir
ils vont la regarder d'accord et ils
vont réfléchir à ce qui est montré
soyons lucides quoi c'est à dire quand
je vois les efforts que nous petits
français à l'intérieur de notre propre
pays on doit faire pour essayer
d'expliquer comment passer à l'offensive
sur tel ou tel aspect de guerre de
l'information
là c'est même plus la quête du graal on
ouvre une parenthèse qui va durer un peu
on va revenir sur la quête du graal est
ce que vous trouvez que nous
renseignements économiques nos cellule
de prospective
et tous ces gentils c'est gentil
personnes qui les composent sont
performants en rapport avec leur temps
dans l'air du temps opérationnel
agressifs et ont réellement pris
conscience des enjeux ou simplement
c'est une bande de plan qui vise deux
ayant fait l'école qu'il fallait qu'ils
se retrouvent dans le cabinet ou dans le
machin ou dans le bidule c'est pas grave
ça se voit pas sur le noir ils se
retrouvent qui se retrouvent dans le
dans la bonne place pour pondre des
papiers qui vont plaire à leur
hiérarchie et ensuite se terminer sur
une petite sauterie rocher suchard dans
une ambassade
j'aime bien est-ce que vous avez compris
ma façon très très peu de écrire j'aime
bien
un pouce et belles scènes de cinéma ça
quelque part qui mériterait d'être
réalisé d'ailleurs bien sûr qu'il ya ça
quelque part et le ca en question s'est
il ya un film je crois qu'ils
s'appellent le mépris
qui est un film absolument remarquable
parce qu'il explique
dans l'image
ce que ce monde-là exprime par rapport
à des gens comme nous quelque part
on se met pour une fois dans la même
barque j'ai pas le choix
on est rien
on aura beau faire des théories
pertinente on aura beau écrire des
grilles de lecture qui ont un quart de
siècle déjà est ce que surtout personne
ne va dire elle existait et voilà qui
les a écrites surtout pas
le mépris donc ce milieu du même
d'expériences de terrain d'ailleurs
mises à part les salons feutrés de la
belle moquette
c'est leur force c'est le mépris
alors on le sait ça mais je veux pas
mettre
tout le monde dans ce bassine d'eau
sale bien entendu quelques pertes
collatérales voilà heureusement
meilleure mais c'est ces gens là
je vais pas le citer mais quand je vois
un haut fonctionnaire qui est censé
avoir une certaine responsabilité et sur
le site qui devrait être ainsi allant
dans le sens que vous dites il ya je ne
sais combien de pages pour expliquer son
parcours de carrière
c'est pas le problème
c'est pas le problème on lui demande pas
ça on lui demande penser agir c'est
autre chose et là c'est pas le parcours
degrés donc vivre sous le mépris
c'est d'abord ne pas se faire détruire 1
2 continuer à exister et la seule
manière d'exister
c'est l'aventuré humaine j'y reviens
mais et cette aventure humaine en france
où est ce qu'on la trouve certainement
pas dans ce cadre supérieur d'un grand
groupe du cac40 qu'il faisait un
commentaire sur les articles que j'ai
mis sur linkedin qu'en dix ans mais
c'est la finance qui dirige tout c'est
fini on parle pas de deux de dépendance
économique
souveraineté industrielle mais mon
pauvre ami ou allez-vous quoi réveiller
vous c'est fini tout ça et là quand je
lis ce type je mets 10 mai
des étudiants qui ont défilé en
septembre 40 sur les champs elysées
il aurait écrit quoi sur ces gens là on
avait été ratiboiser
on était dans une situation
catastrophique
il fallait mieux être des zazous
aller en boîte de nuit et côté du jazz
et ré regarder passer les trains avec ce
qu'ils avaient dans les trains et là il
ya deux catégories d'individus ce que
disent et ce qu'ils regardent passer les
trains je suis pas dans la catégorie qui
regardent passer les trains ça me fait
venir et ça mais je je suis réaliste
ce mépris
à une force existentielle terrible
ils sont aux manettes ils sont commandes
ils ne veulent pas lâcher
ils sont prêts même à dire des choses
incroyables à réécrire l'histoire
en disant mais finalement on l'a
toujours dit ce que vous nous dites et
on a vécu avec sa
donc la wii dans un mot
il ya le problème résumé tant qu'on
n'aura pas dégagé cette réalité de
mépris on n'avancerait pas et c'est pas
parce que il ya effectivement ici et là
des gens très bon dans l'enseignement
dans l'enseignement économie privée dans
des cabinets d'analystes dans le monde
du droit dans dans des groupes il ya
vraiment des
chais pas si c'est des résistants je
sais pas quelle il ya des gens qui
existe il ya des gens qui existe il n'y
a pas des gens qui se contentent de
regarder les trains passer
en faisant semblant de dire mais on
contrôle la circulation des trains en
prime on à contrôler c'est ça notre
pouvoir donc
où on se réveille
on se réveille pas si on se réveille pas
le mépris à vienne
avec ce qu'il ya derrière avec ce qu'il
ya derrière donc on va parler de ce
qu'il ya derrière donc on se retrouve
dans le meilleur des cas borg peut-être
manchot ou sinon totalement
aveugle et et la france va ou dans tout
ça la france avec une crise due qu'aux
vide qui a mis
qui a mille l'économie en apesanteur un
proche de
matières de la falaise
on va changer on va repartir dans le
monde d'après le monde d'avant le monde
2 il ya beaucoup d'éléments de langage
qui sont balancés en ce moment dans les
médias on est dans les cellules des
analyses
encore une fois on est de vendre le bord
de la falaise on est d'accord
donc il va falloir
transformer les mots en actes
transformer les mots en hâte
si le pouvoir politique
ne crée pas un ministère du
développement économique mais pas pour
recycler des de l'écologie verte 1 j'ai
rien contre l'environnement au contraire
mais pour penser ce que doit être
stratégiquement le besoin d'une
relocalisation en venant ici j'ai écouté
une radio que je citerai pas où
quelqu'un disait ah mais on peut pas mon
bon monsieur on peut pas tout
relocaliser c'est pas possible
bah si mon pote il va falloir que ça
soit possible sur sa sueur ça sur sa
sueur ça il va falloir créer des
solutions que ce te plaise ou non à toi
parce que la crise du masque
l'incohérence du système
la manière dont tout ça aurait pu partir
brutalement en sucette parce qu'on a
entre guillemets de la chance qu'on en
soit que sur une épidémie à 30000 morts
et qu'on n'en soit pas sur autre chose
de plus grave d'accord pour l'instant
on verra mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que les décisions qui doivent être
prises c'est pas en jouant les danseuses
avec ceux qui regardent passer les
trains c'est à dire on va attendre que
ça se calme les relocalisations
on va en faire deux ou trois pour amuser
la galerie la production de masques
comme l'a dit je ne citerai pas parce
que lui c'est une distribution de
claques toutes les secondes qui
mériteraient si on n'en trouve pas en
france on en trouvera ailleurs
donc donc sur ce sujet là
c'est pas pour rien que je dis créer un
ministère du développement il est clair
qu'on l'a sans vouloir jouer les
pleureuses mais la disparition du
ministère de l'industrie a été une
erreur majeure il va falloir
reconstituer un système pas une usine à
gaz comme ce que j'ai vu sur internet au
niveau du système de santé français qui
est une véritable catastrophe dans les
logiques de contrôle qui sert
strictement à pas grand-chose pour toute
une partie de ces structures donc il va
falloir des logiques commando des gens
qui en veulent des gens qui sont prêts à
aller chercher des solutions efficaces
qui sont pris aussi aller au carton mais
bien entendu c'est la prise à avoir
c'est la prise de risque est là en
touche
l'autre aspect
déjà on l'a compris l' aventure humaine
c'est pas koh lanta la tuerie je suis
désolé pour grand public français l
aventure humaine c'est autre chose
l'aventuré humaine c'est les tripes
ces lignes en solidarité avec les autres
c'est la théorie du don c'est la théorie
du sacrifice c'est pas faire pendant
trois semaines ceinture en mangeant ché
pas quoi et en ayant cent mille euros si
je gagne c'est pas sale aventure humaine
l'aventuré humaine c'est ce qui permet
un peuple
d'exister même si c'est pas tout le
peuple
si on n'a pas ça
on n'aura quoi
et à côté de l' aventure humaine
oui comme vous dites fallait au carton
cr x faut la prise de risque et le sens
du sacrifice
on peut pas gagner à tous les coups on
va avoir des défaites on va s'affronter
à des forces beaucoup plus importante
que nous mais mais mais on l'a déjà fait
ça
quand on a créé l'armée de l'an 2 qui
était une arme est sorti de nulle part
avec des transfuges de l'armée loyaliste
j'ai noté quand même qu'on avait
affronté toute l'europe monarchistes
et on n'a pas perdu
donc une fois dans notre histoire on a
existé dans un rapport du très très très
faible au fort
et c'est plus possible
évidemment le drame c'est que c'est qui
ceux qui disent que c'est plus possible
ils sont malheureusement dans le monde
économique c'est ce qu'ils mangent bien
la cantine entre autres et
si je vous dis chevaucher le tigre
est ce que est ce que vous pensez pas
que macro est en train de nous
ridiculiser en ce moment est ce que vous
pensez pas que mentir sur les basques ça
vient du fait qu'il est mal renseigné ça
fait bien du fait que quelqu'un lui a
dit non tout ce passe bien madame la
marquise tout va bien ça vient de quoi
est-ce qu'on est ce qu'on a 1 p1
président poète ou est-ce qu'on a un
président qui est totalement hors sol
bah déjà sur les masques quand on fait
trois pas en arrière on se dit comment
oser encore prétendre qu'il n'y a pas eu
de problème de masques
c'est un peu comme si je vais dans la
rue je vois des gens qui sont en train
de crever la gueule ouverte
et jeudi mais en fait ces gens là
cherchent à respirer de l'air pur
il ya un problème je ne comprends pas
comment un homme comme macron ne voit
pas que là il vient de commettre une
erreur politique majeure qui risque tout
simplement de lui coûter l'élection
présidentielle à venir
on peut pas dire une chose pareille
c'est inassumable c'est inassumable
parce que le peuple là je vais pas
parler de la société civile c'est pas
trop ça veut dire le peuple il sait qui
avait pas de masque
moi ma femme a eu copie d' on était dans
un appart il n'y avait pas de masque on
pouvait pas aller en acheter on a eu de
la chance elle n'est pas allée à
l'hôpital et moi je suis toujours là et
mes enfants aussi tous muscu voilà tout
va bien mais voilà quoi mais mais des
situations comme moi et je m'en suis
très très bien tiré mais ceux qui s'en
sont très très mal tiré il n'avait pas
de masse non plus il semble alors
prétendre de dire qu'il ya pas eu de
masques faut le faire quoi non c'est un
conseil
faire un an d'honorables jamais fait ça
il faut le faire parce que là là on est
sur des échelles de richter en terme de
ressenti là ça c'est l'échelle 8
si quelque chose qui passera pas c'est
quelque chose qui te serais je ferai
juste un parallèle flash mais
et je suis bien pas c'est pour le savoir
c'est tellement compliqué d'expliquer
aux gens il faut se battre pour la
france pour son peuple son territoire
son développement économique
quand je parlais comme ça honnêtement je
passais pour un singe damang point à la
ligne maintenant c'est m c'est un peu
différent quoique
parce que faut trouver les combattants
pas des combattants maï en a pas tant
que ça pourquoi il n'a pas tant que ça
parce qu'on tombe sur ce qu'on disait
tout à l'heure
qu'est ce qu'ils savent de l' aventure
humaine
comment on a ça quoi comment on le vit
parce que là le combat c'est aussi de
l'amour je vais pas jouer peace and lobe
le combat c'est l'amour
de ce qu'on ressent de l'action de la
beauté de l'action sur du rêve mais bien
sûr mais c'est lié aussi à l'autre chose
c'est à dire on prend des coups
obligatoirement donc il faut prendre des
risques
donc il faut qu'on trouve des individus
pour accepter ça
se battre pour la france aujourd'hui
c'est pas partir dans des aventures
néocolonial je ne sais quoi non se
battre pour la france et pour que ce
peuple
ne s'enlise pas dans ces contradictions
pour aboutir à un grand n'importe quoi
donc pour ne pas s'enliser dans ses
contradictions et aboutir à un grand
n'importe quoi d'abord on commence à
reconnaître des choses oui a eu un
problème sur les masques et c'est au
président de la république au premier
des français d'avoir leur mettez
intellectuelle de le dire et personne ne
lui jettera la pierre à partir du moment
où il aura ce courage car ça c'est du
courage politique ne pas avoir ce
courage politique c'est mettre sa tête
sur le billot il n'y a pas de guillotine
mais ça sera le bulletin de vote qui
servira de guillotine parce qu'il ya des
choses qui sont impardonnables
on ne peut pas pardonner ça c'est pas
possible vous parlez de séisme politique
comment ça se passe la prospective sur
l'anticipation d'une insurrection
sociale d'une crise financière à une
épidémie de covin du non respect des
politiques énormément de mépris
[Musique]
saisie
si on veut anticiper la catastrophe il
faut que les gens se battent pour le
collectif il ya un mot dont j'ai horreur
dans le vocabulaire administratif c'est
l'intérêt général
parce que dans le mot général c'est un
peu je prends un sachet de sucre et
jeudi loup dans l'eau et je ne le vois
plus sucre l'intérêt collectif on sait
qu'on se bat pour quelque chose pour
éviter les crises en france il faut
qu'on arrive à ce que des gens
travaillent ensemble sur des choses
aussi modeste soit elle je prends un
exemple un jour je vais en alsace je
vais dans une chambre de commerce à
colmar et là je tombe sur un jeune type
qui avaient un diplôme l'intelligence
économique en poche et qu'il dit vous
savez là nous on a une expérience où on
a recréé de l'activité économique
pour moi ça c'est la quête du graal
justement et comment ils ont fait en
huit heures dans une vallée il y avait
le chômage les entreprises était
quasiment morte et là il ya quelques
patrons quelques patrons de cette vallée
qu'en décidé de réfléchir ensemble et
qu'on crée des
micro-entreprises au départ sur le
problème du handicap pour aider le monde
du handicap et ça a commencé à marcher
et les gens se sont fait confiance et
jean ont créé un microcosme économique
viable donc quand je prends un exemple
comme ça la priorité des priorités
aujourd'hui dans un pays comme le nôtre
ça doit partir des territoires ça doit
partir des capacités de réunir des
individus qui pour des raisons x ou y
vont avoir envie d'aller dans cette
trajectoire est là bien sûr le vrai
problème c'est d'être soyons un peu
asiatique entre guillemets c'est à dire
ne soyons pas dans le rattrapage se
soyons dans le raccourci utilisons le
net vous aide dans le monde du net vous
savez ce qu'on peut en tirer vous savez
toute la force là on a été en
télétravail coup de chance pendant
plusieurs semaines là c'était un moyen
de faire comprendre aux gens que c'est
pas simplement passer du temps devant un
écran à rêvasser c'est aussi travailler
c'est aussi produire des choses c'est
aussi trouver des solutions c'est gros
c'est du goût mais bien sûr aussi mais
c'est c'est aussi faire de la créativité
sur des solutions donc ce coup de fouet
et là
il faut le traduire en acte mais
attention encore une fois pas avec les
gens qui regardent passer les trains
pas avec les administrations qui
s'enlise dans leur inertie j'ouvre une
parenthèse pour passer une question de
la communauté comment fait tout pour
débarquer ce qu'ils regardent passer les
trains et ceux qui remettent du charbon
dans la locomotive
alors je vais prendre déjà l'exemple du
charmant et locomotives moi j'ai eu la
chance
de croiser des syndicalistes il y a
trois quatre ans
et je m'attendais pas à les voir parce
qu'il y avait des gens du syndicat sud
et des gens du syndicat
cfe cgc
saboter les locomotives non non non si
les des gens qui étaient à belfort
et qui avait vécu la crise alstom est en
fait on a travaillé ensemble sur une
question qui n'était qu'il n'avait rien
à voir avec le syndicalisme qui était
mais comment
construire à partir d'un territoire qui
est menacé par tout un tas de choses
trouver les solutions et là on vient à
l'information c'est à dire où sont les
expériences comment on regarde autour
est ce qu'on peut se réapproprier des
choses autour de quoi on est parti avant
même de parler de ça c'est quoi notre
histoire économique
quelles sont les traces qu'est ce qui a
marché qu'est-ce qui survit qu'est ce
qui a disparu pourquoi c'est à dire
cette mémoire opérationnel absolument
indispensable du vécu du territoire
qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur ce
territoire et comment à partir de là je
vais enrichir le bilan avec des
expériences voir ce qui est transposable
et comment obligatoirement la faut que
je crée un dispositif ce fameux commando
c'est quoi ce commando c'est des gens
qui vont commencer à créer un réseau
avec
ce qui existe aux calmants et en voyant
ou et la vie qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe ils réunissent
plusieurs dizaines de chefs de pme
théoriquement c'est vers eux qu'il faut
aller pas de chance qu'est ce qu'ils
lisent les chefs de pme ils disent nous
on veut des contrats tout de suite ce
que vous nous dites
on n'a pas le temps donc là déjà on a
une photo réaliste c'est pas avec eux
qu'on va pouvoir travailler tout de
suite donc où sont les autres forces où
on peut faire du concret où on peut
aller chercher des solutions
deuxième problème j'avais face à moi des
militants
donc des gens qui savent ce que ça veut
dire de travailler pour le collectif
mais ils m'ont dit et c'était des
ingénieurs en partie ils m'ont dit notre
problème c'est qu'on n'a pas le temps on
n'a pas le temps en dehors de notre
boulot de la vie de famille d'élever les
gosses et c'est de faire ce que vous
nous suggérer c'est à dire de créer une
logique commando sur une base
complètement gratuite au départ pour
créer cet embryon informationnel parce
que fo grève il faut greffer des forces
là dessus et là je me retrouve toujours
devant la case départ
comment faire où aller les chercher les
combattants comment on va arriver enfin
à créer ces c'est c'est toute petite
unité de combat informationnel ou
cognitif peu importe où on va faire du
renseignement où on va faire de
l'analyse où on va essayer de comprendre
on va essayer de regarder et quand je
parle de travail et les ja tic jeu par
les draps concis mais les japonais les
coréens du sud et les chinois qu'est-ce
qu'ils ont faits ils ont fait exactement
ça bon il ya un exemple qui m'a marqué
parce qu'il est gravé au fer rouge la
guerre économique
c'est pas bernard esambert qu'on a parlé
la guerre économique le premier en avoir
par goût oui mais à mai mais avant lui
avant lui c'est un type que personne n'a
connu qui s'appelle anthony xhaka qui a
écrit dans les années 30 un bouquin sur
le pétrole et un bouquin sur le japon et
qui rappelle cette scène extraordinaire
d'un député à l'assemblée nationale qui
brandit un t-shirt 1930-31 je sais plus
ils vont détruire notre industrie
textile
années 30 d'accor oublie oubliettes
terminée mais avant même sa monsieur
antoine de tarlé secrétaire général de
la chambre de commerce de lyon en
1916-17 il traduit un bouquin écrit par
un ingénieur allemand herzog et le
regard d'information monsieur de tarlé
ils appellent ça le plan de guerre
commerciale de l'allemagne premier
chapitre tout commerce est une guerre ce
bouquin est traduit par le président des
états unis qui le type qui va devenir
président des états unis dix ou quinze
ans après on a oublié tout ça d'accord
on a oublié tout ça donc notre problème
je reviens toujours à l'essentiel c'est
comment arriver à trouver des forces
mobilisables des gens qui ont du temps
des gens qui sont prêts à se battre pour
ce pays au sens où je le dis et des gens
lucides y en a je répète des
syndicalistes avait plein de choses à
dire un exemple très intéressant
general electric
general electric un moment donné dit
changement d'axés stratégiques ont fait
plus de recherche développement on va se
mettre en embuscade on va balance on va
partir sur la logique purement
financière et on va se mettre en
embuscade pour racheter des boîtes qui
elle fonda recherche développement qui
auront fait la démonstration qu'elles
sont rentables et on les rachète
d'accord seulement il ya un petit
problème c'est qu'il ya toujours le
système productif general electric hélas
les syndicalistes ont comme quoi ça sert
les syndicalistes ils ont découvert quoi
c'est que général electric avait mis au
point un système de reporting hors sol
pour faire croire qu'il continue et aide
dans une logique de recherche des bleus
alors là on n'est pas à moscou on n'est
pas à pékin on est ailleurs
est ce que je veux dire par là c'est que
cette analyse de syndicalistes là où il
ya un problème c'est qu'il faudrait que
ça remonte
en eau du système syndical
parce que ça c'est un élément de
démonstration intéressant et ma question
pourquoi ça remonte jamais en eau
pour remercier tous les syndicalistes
qui nous envoie à bord de l'information
tout à fait et spécialement ceux qui
travaillent ils ont compris qu'ils se
sont confinés avec leur outil de travail
merci et merci beaucoup parenthèse
fermée
macron macro chevaucher le tigre guerre
économique son petit speech pour dire oh
lalala lalala il y à des puissances
étrangères prédatrice ouh la la la la la
la il faut qu'on se ressaisisse à
l'échelle européenne
c'est pas du foutage de gueule on a vu
technip se faire désosser alstom se
faire désosser qui d'autre là où là
encore on encore une entreprise en
tunisie qui est en train de mettre la
clé sous la porte et il ya eu cette
entreprise c'est intéressant d'ailleurs
ce cas-là cette entreprise qui était une
petite entreprise très très bien
positionnée sur la vision nocturne
qui était en train d'être racheté et là
il a fallu intra muros la menace d'une
guerre de l'information
pour pour qu'il dise non non non
finalement assez dessus on les a tombé
elle sera pas racheter mais notez bien
il a fallu la menace intra muros d'une
guerre de l'information
c'est pas une pensée stratégique enfin
arrivé par les astres d'accord donc donc
là on est on est effectivement l'image
l'aiment bien l'image du rebord de la
falaise parce que s'il ya bien une chose
qu'il faut pas faire en politique c'est
de dire voilà la situation voilà le
rapport de force et nous allons
agir
ah oui
et comment
comment on va faire pour agir parce que
là il s'agit pas d'être dans le mépris
salir les gens qui vivent dans le mépris
ils peuvent pas se voir très faible par
rapport au fort on est dans un rapport
très faible par rapport au fort
donc que c'est mal barré en termes d'
adn
eux il regarde du haut vers le bas et
regarde pas du bas vers le haut or notre
situation c'est de regarder du bas vers
le haut c'est de regarder où on va
trouver des failles où on va enfin
exploiter des marges de manoeuvre et là
on a un terrible défi qui s'appelle la
pédagogie j'ai mis en ligne a pas
longtemps sur un site un article sur sur
le prime du monde de l'ingénieur en
france c'est un monde extraordinaire
c'est une des raisons d'être de la
richesse française
patrouilleurs économique les entreprises
climat crouesty discours normé juge
juste ça parce qu'on a besoin de ce
mandat mais ce monde là tant qu'il aura
les yeux rivés sur l'innovation et qu'il
ira pas vers la guerre économique
c'est des divisions qui ne sont pas
mobiles c'est des divisions même qu'ils
s'écartent de l'objectif c'est ça le
problème donc revenons sur la question
qui est hyper importante
c'est quoi la guerre économique de la
france dans l'après qu'ovide
l'europe
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui
elle est totalement incapable de définir
des stratégies
de guerre économique
elle va jouer sur des aspects financiers
sur des aspects réglementaires
elle pourra éventuellement jouer sur des
stratégies de grains de sable avec des
barrières à l'entrée lié à telle ou
telle
décision
mais pas de stratégie industriel parce
que c'est pas possible parce que c'est
pas dans leur adn or il nous faut à tout
prix des stratégies industrielles
je dis pas ça comme staline qui voulait
créer forcément sidérurgie etc je dis
qu'on en a besoin donc l'europe elle ne
nous donnera que 15 à 20% si on sait
l'utiliser non pas de la réponse mais
des d'éventuels moyens pour commencer à
penser à une stratégie mais les
stratégies en question c'est en france
qu'il va falloir les attendait et avec
un défi majeur
c'est qu'il va falloir sortir du rapport
grands comptes sous traitants
il va falloir sortir de la vampirisation
des groupes par rapport aux entreprises
moyennes petites ou très petites
il va falloir enfin comme le font les
allemands d'ailleurs laissé des marges
de manoeuvre à des plus petits
parce que la reconstruction sur les
territoires sans passer par la
sempiternelle
attractivité du territoire par le
capital étranger non
à partir des ressources locales ou des
ressources environnantes humaine ça
c'est une autre chose c'est un autre
disque donc ça c'est évident que ça
nécessite un travail
très dur
2 pédagogie
et le problème c'est que la pédagogie ça
prend beaucoup de temps je vais pas dire
qu'il faut une révolution culturelle en
france c'est bien que s'est mal terminée
en chine mais il n'empêche que tant
qu'on n'aura pas au sein du monde
étudiant non pas des types qui vont se
défouler en faisant péter des pylônes
mais des gens qui vont se dire
je étudiant
et je vais commettre un acte audacieux
je vais essayer de travailler
pour un collectif
pour l'un une invention économique
travailler avec la modernité
informationnel qu'offre internet et tout
ce que ça représente
travailler en partageant non pas être un
ti est individualiste à trois balles
qui laisse crever l'autre sur le palier
d'à côté parce que c'est pas son
problème non travaillé dans des logiques
collectives car ça ou d'un système
éducatif qui est fait pour élever des
bébés requins aux amandes de requin ou
le but du jeu c'est tuer l'eau ça n'a
pas été évident elle se passe dans les
écoles de métiers mise pour des croche
patte heathfield et fukui ainsi de suite
dans les autres dans les autres si c'est
la même chose c'est ça va pas être
évident mais je sais que quel était le
philosophe qui disait
j'ai introduit
celui qui dit je résume trivialement
notre système éducatif
n'est fait que pour sélectionner les
plus cinglés les plus les plus
chauds n'est pas qu'il vous dira
donc parce que notre système éducatif et
phélippeau pour sélectionner les plus
cinglés
on a un système éducatif qui n'apprend
pas à se battre collectivement points et
le drame de ça c'est que c'est le
résultat
d'une histoire politique
c'est à dire que n'oublions jamais une
chose c'est que le monde éducatif il
était théoriquement à l'extrême gauche
et à gauche
ou si comme nous oui mais enfin il y
avait quand même beaucoup de gens je
parle des instits je parle des profs de
bahut et c est très bizarrement moi ce
que j'ai vécu à travers un période
scolaire mais comme comme tous les
autres c'est qu'on avait en face de nous
des gens qui pourraient à l'extrême
gauche ou à gauche et qui disait
occupe toi de tes résultats et le
système était polarisé sur l'individu et
le collectif là je parle pas de
l'émulation les travaux de groupe qu'on
imagine dans la déconstruction du
système d'air dont je parle comment on
gagne ensemble comment on se mobilisent
ensemble comment on arrive à utiliser
ensemble des outils des technologies de
l'information etc ca et du résultat mais
ça effectivement ça s'apprend moi je
garde en mémoire quelque chose qui m'a
marqué j'avais eu un jour un étudiant
indien que je remercie qui venait de
l'epita donc qui vient de votre monde et
qui me disait la très bonne école
exactement et qui me disait qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait l'inde l'un à un moment
donné et c'est une décision pas des
entreprises indiennes c'est l'inde qui a
dit
il faut qu'on crée une industrie
d'informatique
pour ce faire on va pendant x années
modifier nos programmes d'enseignement
en mettant de côté tel aspect et en
privilégiant telle autre avant lui map
initiation à l'informatique etc
et ils l'ont fait et ils l'ont fait et
le résultat il suffit d'aller en main
pour voir ce qu'est l'industrie
informatique en gaine indienne pardon et
le nombre et le nombre d'ingénieurs
qu'ils ont créés comme ça c'était une
décision politique ça la méthode n'est
pas enseigné à l'insee end
c'est un pays qui
veut pas crever la gueule ouverte qui
veut exister qui veut créer un système
pour se développer
l'exemple industrie informatique en quoi
nous on n'arriverait pas à voir une
telle créativité à notre niveau par
rapport à des potentiels pourquoi on
pourrait pas faire des choses
équivalente de cette nature en quoi ce
serait choquant plutôt que de voir
arriver des réformes de déstructuration
du système éducatif pour acheter la paix
sociale parce que faut quand même être
très très clair dans un cynisme ou on
n'achète que dalle en fait puisqu'on on
a l'impression d'acheter la paix sociale
mais on mean toutes les bases
une réalité territoriale qui va tôt ou
tard
nous exploser à la figure
c'est tellement évident tout ça alors
que si on faisait des choses concrètes
si on arrivait enfin
vous parler oui il faut faire rêver les
gens sur des choses où ils ont
l'impression d'avancer ensemble et pas
on sera content de bêtises avec des
résultats on regarde par exemple les
compagnons comme des des rescapés
historique
d'une séparation de la terre j'ai
l'impression le compagnonnage qu'il est
beau le compagnonnage on dirait qu'ils
sont déjà plaqué sur un mur comme des
des effigies de musée mais est on peut
pas inventer d'autres chemins du même
type sur d'autres terrains dans le monde
immatériel par exemple sans que ça soit
forcément
la logique start over avec ce qu'elle
peut avoir de bien et aussi de très
destructif
le l'auteur que cherchait c'était albert
jacquard et c'est là
la communauté qui a pallié mon trou de
mémoire je le remercie beaucoup mercier
la communauté
on est en train de sélectionner les gens
les plus dangereux
pour revenir à notre copie de 19 à votre
avis si ça continue comme ça on va se
taper un kobe de vin est ce que les
cellules de prospective anticipe c'est
ce qu'ils font des plans
ce que je comprends pas c'est que
l'épidémie de 2003 ou prenez moi si je
me trompe on avait déjà commencé à faire
de la veille dessus
et les chaînes de télé pour certaines
les plus grosses avait déjà fait un plan
pandémie avec un mec capable d'alimenter
la télé française avec un seul bouton
pendant trois mois avec des programmes
déjà prêt déjà regardé déjà exfiltré de
deux bouts de soutiens gorges joue de
mots graveleux et
comment comment on explique qu'on soit
7,7 prospectifs cette anticipation
c'est un sketch oui mais c'est ça leur
sol
c'est à dire que moi ça me fait rire
moderne post moderne non je dirais sol
et hors sol pour moi c'est plus simple
comme grille de lecture c'est à dire
leur sol c'est oublier que quand on
dirige un pays
faut mettre les pieds dans la merde quoi
pour parler vulgairement
occident
accessoirement non mais non mais c'est
une évidence c'est une évidence et et ça
veut dire justement comment on les sort
de la merde ses pieds comment on
commence à enfin réagir sur des choses
pertinentes
comment ont créé de l'espoir comment on
crée de l'engouement et comment aussi on
est capable de dire aux gens vous allez
prendre des coups et ya des risques
par les enfumer en disant vous preniez
ce chemin là tout va bien se passer vous
aurez tel niveau de salaire dans dix ans
et c est penser d'abord à vous un
bon c'est proton
comment on fait pour durcir la sécurité
économique du pays
et comment on forme les analystes c'est
quoi un bon analyste
un bon anaïs et quelqu'un déjà acquis on
on apprend la curiosité alors y'en a qui
sont curieux de nature heureusement
d'air mais il faut pas qu'à curiosité
je parlais tout à l'heure du grand défi
de la pédagogie en a un deuxième qui
pour moi est monumentale c'est qu'il
faut réapprendre à lire
fahrenheit 451 qui était bradbury ma
fille très beau film de science fiction
est un très beau roman en fait il est
mort si nous sismologues il et il était
très pro mais une histoire
parce qu'en fait on les a pas brûler les
livres
on les a simplement ignorés et moi
la souffrance de chaque enseignant
parce que quelque part c'est un peu ça
je dis pas ça pour jouer chez pas quoi
mais c'est de voir des gens qui n'aiment
pas lire compass compris l'intérêt de la
lecture qui n'ont pas compris qu'ils
sont dans un siècle où on a une chance
extraordinaire c'est d'avoir des
ouvrages que l'on appelle les ouvrages
grille de lecture qui permettent d'en
lire 1 et non pas 30 et d'en tirer la
substance substantifique moelle parce
qu'il ya cette qualité là parce que
l'humanité a progressé certes à dose
homéopathique mais qu'elle a sa sous la
main hier comment on réapprend lire
réapprendre à lire c'est par le combat
c'est que quelqu'un qui se bat qui
comprend que lire ça va lui être utile
ce sera d'autant plus facile pour qu'ils
aient envie de lire
c'est pas simplement à loisir c'est pas
parce qu'on est confiné six semaines
qu'on va être obligé finalement de se
taper le bouquin qu'on n'a jamais lu
qu'on a eu à noël et qui nous donnait de
l'urticaire non mais comment on fait et
çà
et là
oui internet doit être utile réapprendre
à lire c'est qu'il faut qu'on ait des
sites qui explique l'intérêt d'un
bouquin qui crée des je dirais des focus
en disant voilà ce que je sors du
bouquin il ya cette pépite dans ce
bouquin elle peut être utile car la
pépie plat regarde là bien
pourquoi elle va être utile
je prends un exemple je lis un bouquin
qui est qui est inégal mais qui est
intéressant histoire de la guerre je
tombe sur un article
j'apprends que durant la seconde guerre
mondiale il y avait 2 millions d'indiens
sous l'uniforme britannique
2 millions
alors c'est une information qui peut
paraître sans intérêt et bigrement
intéressante pour tout un tas de raisons
quand je commence à tirer le fil sur la
manière dont les britanniques ont
administré leur empire par exemple et
c'est pas du tout la même chose en ordre
de grandeur que le nôtre
ce qui m'intéresse moi c'est comment on
apprend à tirer une pépite d'un bouquin
comment on la transforme en savoir faire
utile comment on la greffe comme
comme quelqu'un qui grèvent des plantes
pour en faire quelque chose de vivant
cette pédagogie la internet doit être un
support majeur il faut qu'il y ait des
gens qui bossent là dessus qu'ils
gagnent leur vie en faisant ça qu'ils
soient des gens qui transmettent l'envi
de la lecture de l'assimilation de la
connaissance mais pour arriver à des
choses concrètes parce que sinon ça
marche pas une autre question comment on
fait pour reconquérir notre autonomie de
pensée à l'échelle géopolitiques
géostratégiques dans la prospective
comment on fait pour reconquérir cette
autonomie de pensée vous comprenez ma
question oui je pense d'abord qu'il faut
cette question
je pense que sans autonomie de pensée
c'est fini c'est le point de départ
il faut l'autonomie de pensée même ce
que je viens de dire la cie en amont il
n'ya pas l'autonomie de pensée ça sert à
rien et l'autonomie de pensée
c'est avoir la lucidité
avoir la lucidité par exemple c est
capable non pas simplement de regarder
sur canal+ la série sur louis xiv mais
c'est de se dire le jour où on a
planté dans le saint-empire romain
germanique
en faisant deux choses
pas terrible
c'est à dire en s'alliant avec nous et
demie religieux
sacrés 1 un brouillage sur la ligne
d'accord puisque on s'est allié aux
protestants pour planter les princes
catholiques allemands alors que nous on
combattait les protestants voyez déjà le
bien sûr oui mais parasitage lourd je
fais le 6 2 et a des problèmes d'argent
bien sûr
l'alliance avec empire ottoman il y en a
qu'on peut être considéré que c'était
super rare de la manoeuvre en prenant à
contre-pied c'est se tirer une balle
dans la tête tout simplement et tant
qu'on ne regarde parce que pourquoi je
dis ça parce que l'histoire entre la
france et l'allemagne
faut quand même qu'on soit pas assez
naïf pour croire qu'avec le traité de
westphalie où on pète l'allemagne sur
trois siècles on a des membres en les
allemands ils vont être là en train de
déguster leurs bières avec un vraiment
un sourire jovial en disant allez france
aux
cabines telegent
faut arrêter là donc les allemands ils
ont aiguisé leurs rasoirs on a commencé
à vivre avoir le sentiment du rasoir
dans les guerres napoléoniennes
mais on a commencé surtout avoir le
rasoir lui même dans les écrits de
bismarck qu'est ce qui motive et
bismarck d'esprit de revanche
parce que n'oublions jamais il ya
beaucoup de livres d'histoire français
qui disent c'est une super victoire
stratégique le traité de westphalie à la
manière dont on a pété le saint-empire
romain germanique on l'assument pas en
plus on ne les assume pas
donc une autonomie de pensée
c'est regarder ça en face c'est de se
dire c'était pas forcément si génial que
ça puisque derrière on se dit pris trois
guerres dans la tronche
soixante dix on l'a perdu 14 18
on l'a gagnée mais à quel prix et 40 on
a été dégagée d'accord même si on a
ressuscité grâce à un type qui est parti
à londres qui s'appelle le général de
gaulle et car construit quelque chose
tant bien que mal et c'était pas gagné
bon
il faut faire cet effort
autre exemple parce qu'il faut rentrer
dans le dur là je me souviens un jour
un conseiller culturel d'un ministre que
j'ai croisés qui était un juge me disait
il faut que tu écrives un bouquin sur
pourquoi le mot patriotisme en france
et exploser
et jeudi effectivement il ya un fil
conducteur qui est intéressant à creuser
une force française s'allient à des
forces étrangères qui nous ont battu
militairement et qui occupe note ça
a déjà où est le patriotisme
1870 une force français s'allie à un
pays qui nous a vaincu militairement
deuxième crise grave dans la
compréhension des choses
une force française collabore avec
l'allemagne nazie pour sauver les
meubles dit-on
à la sortie d' ces trois trucs là
comment voulez vous que les français
il voit clair dans la définition du
patriotisme
ne l'a d'abord sans filtre j'en profite
je profite pour qu'elle ait une question
des communautés c'est donc c'est quand
même pas trop triste et comment on fait
pour garder do do talon alors que
l'argent manque
d'abord le patriotisme penser d'être
lucide il ait sa propre histoire
l'histoire française escale hier on ne
fera pas il ya eu trois crises qui ont
pété ce mot là parce que les gens après
savait plus où il habite et
quentin un
groupe d'un peuple s'allie avec les
militaires qui t'a battu pour parler
vulgairement
comment tu fais dans ta tête comment tu
géré ça quand ça se passe trois fois de
suite en un siècle et demi comment tu en
sors pourquoi je dis ça parce que toute
ma jeunesse passée en lorraine dans la
meuse à verdun où aston et ou ailleurs
mais toutes les discussions du dimanche
c'était cette espèce de ressasser où les
gens ne se ne se retrouvait plus n'avait
plus de point de repère savait plus où
il habite est d'accord donc ça ça marque
et ça veut dire que pour répondre à
votre question
il faut cette lucidité il faut cette
publicité pour
n'ont pas évacué mais pour arriver à la
synthèse pour comprendre qu'ils aient eu
des problèmes pour comprendre qu'il faut
dépasser ses problèmes qu'il faut aller
de l'avant qu'il faut reconstituer
effectivement bonne question c'est quoi
le patriotisme aujourd'hui moi ma
définition est simple c'est un peuple
sur un territoire faire en sorte qu'ils
ne crève pas et faire en sorte qu'il
continue à exister faire en sorte qu'il
ne devienne pas n'importe quoi qu'il ose
se regarder en face elle est très simple
définition une question la communauté
qui sera en deux parties j arrive à
attraper l'écran correctement merci on
fait quoi après le coc vide la chine
repart et on pollue plus qu'avant le
confinement on fait quoi du capitalisme
in stein disait la vraie folie c'est de
faire toujours les mêmes choses et
d'attendre un résultat différent
on a une épée de damoclès au dessus de
nos têtes c'est que ces clubs pros ne
sera pas réglé
quels problèmes sont probables du
problème des pandémies et du risque de
répétition
et éventuellement du risque n'oublions
pas que
montmagny une qualité première c'est pas
avoir de mémoire c'est à dire la grippe
espagnole la grippe asiatique en 68 ce
qui est extraordinaire
je ne savais même pas qu'elle existait
je suis un des français parmi d'autres
ont même pas su qu'il y avait une grippe
asiatique en 68 9 qui a tué plus de
monde que le colis de 19 par exemple
quid
donc on a cette épée damoclès on sait
qu'il va falloir
dialoguer quitte à tordre certains brap
pour qu'on ne se reprenne pas une fois
de suite une fois de plus ce pardon ce
genre de choses donc là on a un vrai
problème moi je note il ya un exemple
que j'ai en tête tant il ya eu
tchernobyl le réflexe des soviétiques
dans un premier temps ça a été bien
entendu de de
limiter la casse au maximum en termes de
perte d'image mais je note quand même
que les russes ont confié au groupe
vinci la construction de la deuxième
cloche sûre cette centrale c'est un
groupe russe qui l'a construite c'est un
groupe d'origine française qui appelle
vinci ça pour moi ça participe d'une
coopération intelligente est nécessaire
et utile
par rapport à la pandémie ou par rapport
aux problèmes y ait cette pandémie il
faut la même et là il faut sortir des
pièges faut sortir des pièges
géopolitique c'est à dire que faut pas
que les un noyau de telles institutions
à leur profit le débat autour de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé par
exemple il faut que le parti communiste
chinois
parce que lui aussi il à se regarder
dans la glace
il accepte une coopération
internationale sans perdre la face c'est
pas le problème parce qu'elle est
nécessaire il faut aussi que côté
occidental
quand j'entends la déclaration de
certains groupes pharmaceutiques des
patriotes le directeur général du groupe
sanofi
mais comment il a pu dire un truc pareil
lundi déjà il a dit si un vaccin
développé c'est d'abord les américains
parce que parce que c'est eux qui
financent
principal
alors là j'avoue que c'est les bras m'en
tombent corps de ces on habite ou et on
est un pays super démocrate parce qu'il
est toujours en poste
c'est pas un problème légal il a écrit
une lettre d'excusés c'est la première
fois peut-être dans l'histoire d'un
groupe capitaliste qu un type ses
excuses auprès de tous les salariés
très fort
attendez on n'est pas dans la commedia
dell'arte on est dans la vraie vie on
n'est pas dans le hors sol on est les
pieds sur le sol d'accord avec
éventuellement les aspects désagréable
du sol que j'évoquais tout à l'heure
donc il ya un problème il ya un problème
c'est que là effectivement
si on ne crée pas une communauté
internationale comme il a pu en existait
une pour éviter l'affrontement
thermonucléaire entre puissants sur la
guerre froide n'oubliez pas qu'il ya eu
cet échange entre scientifiques dans le
nucléaire militaire pour éviter le pire
ça a été utile je pense qu'aujourd'hui
dans le domaine médical par rapport aux
problèmes notamment de virus etc il faut
qu'ils aient cette communauté
internationale pour qu'ils aient cette
communauté internationale il faut
d'abord que les scientifiques
arrête de se déchirer la tête sur des
histoires du type raout et c'est parce
que là c'est là on a donné un spectacle
qui est je qualifierais pas il faut
vraiment qu'on est dans sept comités
siens dans cette communauté scientifique
des gens courageux comme ils ont existé
dans la communauté nucléaire à une
certaine époque pour éviter le pire
justement et là c'est d'abord aux
scientifiques de se prendre en main pour
dialoguer entre eux or system pour
arriver à faire avancer les solutions
d'autre part
il faut que nous d'époque je dis bien
les peuples soient vigilants sur le fait
la santé c'est pas simplement un marché
les gars c'est sauver notre peau
et ceux qui croient que c'est un marché
en oubliant le fait de sauver sa peau
attention c'est un jeu dangereux
et j'ai une question concernant je
regarde juste la liste de la communauté
ok on va parler à structure fille un peu
dans pas très longtemps
j'ai
donc parlons à structure film tout de
suite et parlons manipulation des sur
les réseaux manipulation d'opinion
publique ingérence extérieure
je vous laisse la parole est ce que on a
une situation si si si j'ai la question
qui regarde ça c'est ça la question
d'après à l'école de guerre économique
est ce qu'on parle d'effondrement de
collapse au logis de d'épuisement des
ressources d'épuisement du du biotope de
nom soutenabilité du système actuel de
pourrissement tels que le biotope va
nous des coups de pied au cul
alors j'ai eu le plaisir un jour de
coacher une étude
dejean formation continue donc des gens
qui travaillent déjà et qu'on sorti une
étude la première partie de l'étude
c'était de faire le calendrier de toutes
les ressources qu'ils allaient
disparaître logiquement en fonction des
réserves identifiées
et c'est vrai que ça c'est un calendrier
qui fout la trouille parce que là on les
voit
les dates
approximatives
d'épuisement des prospectives grâce à
cela les émeutes de la faim les
révolutions en liga tic obligatoirement
parce que là là là c'est pas parce qu'on
va creuser plus profond peut-être que
comme avec le pétrole on aura des bonnes
surprises mais c'est pas si simple donc
déjà il ya cette vérité là qu'il faut
regarder comment évolue la terre qu'est
ce qui reste comment on va gérer ça on
n'est pas dans un puits sans fin c'est à
dire qu'il y a eu beau obligatoirement
on entre dans la période de vie de
l'humanité où il faut réfléchir à un mot
un peu compliqué que personne ne veut
entendre en france n'est pas la
résidence comment mais la résilience pas
là compresses d'eau chaude sur le front
parce qu'on a vécu la crise donc comment
on disparaît pas justement comment on va
prendre en compte cette réalité là alors
c'est pour moi un problème aussi
important que ce que je définis c'est
tout à l'heure pour créer de l'activité
et là il faut pas inventer une nouvelle
catégorie de rentiers c'est à dire des
gens qui vont être hors sol qui vont se
gargariser qui vont se coller une
étiquette en disant je souffre je suis
les nouveaux maîtres de la nouvelle loi
et qui en fait servi on a que dalle
d'accord qui serviront à rien donc là il
faut définir secret ce qu'est le
contraire je prends un exemple tout bête
très basique
au niveau de l'agriculture
moi je souhaiterais une simple chose
c'est que les gens qui définit ce droit
le calq et hyper important en france qui
croise deux mondes
l'environnement est là duction et qu'on
voit ce que ça donne ce croisement là de
manière lucide et non pas qu'on voit
apparaître deux camps
ceux qui produisent avec des logiques
qui sont pas toujours les meilleurs
et ceux qui avec une idéologie écolo ou
je sais pas quoi occupe le terrain de la
loi sans se préoccuper et logique de
survie sans se préoccuper des réalités
de production sans se préoccuper même de
ce que j'appelais tout à l'heure la
mémoire opérationnel de la terre
comment ça fonctionne tout ça qu'est ce
qui peut être fait fuchs et deux lignes
se croisent si ces deux mondes
s'ignorent chacun dans leurs petites
alvéoles ça marchera pas ça c'est un
vrai défi c'est un défi pour moi aussi
important que le premier
mais on retombe toujours sur le même
problème qui va se battre comment
comment on va créer ces réseaux de
recomposition de la pensée on revient
toujours à la même chose l'autonomie de
pensée comment on va créer sa
war
nous revenons à la deuxième question qui
a été posée avant la première la
structure fine les ingérences
extérieures
la population qui est livré à tous les
vents de toutes les propagandes
comment on fait pour lutter contre ça
comment on fait pour les identifier et
la question qui va suivre après c'est
qu'ils identifient les menaces et
comment on les traite
alors
en restant toujours archi modeste et
parce que c'est à mon avis l'essentiel
comme posture
il ya des pays qui sont à la manoeuvre
et d'autres qui ne savent pas l'être ou
d'autres véhicules
ceux qui sont à la manoeuvre c'est ceux
qui ont une vraie culture de la guerre
de l'information au sens historique les
etats unis la russie
israël qu atteindre la grande bretagne
oui enfin le dandy saoudite we dance est
sûre qui bien sûr puisque c'est des
logiques enfin l'iran aussi à sa manière
mais c'est des logiques
tellement
incontournable par rapport à leur propre
contexte qui sont à la mode et qui
dépensent de l'argent pour ça qu'ils
utilisent soit des forces mercenaires
soit des forces issues de leur propre
dynamique nationale et autres on sait
qu'ils existent
ça fait quoi
la france sur la guerre de l'information
par le contenu j'ai une image insiste en
40 elles avaient des chars qui n'avaient
pas de radio en 2020 elle n'a pas de
chars et pas de radio alors il y en a
qui peuvent considérer que c'est une
avancée technique
j'en suis pas sûr
et évidemment c'est un cidre au qui sur
sa peau sourire mais c'est la réalité et
on a bien vu dans la rédaction des
livres blancs où il fallait déjà tordre
le cou d'un certain nombre de gens pour
qu'ils acceptent que sur le contenant là
on parle du contenu que sur le contenant
c'est à dire tout ce qui est
l'informatique la guerre informatique
la guerre par réseau là et c'est là on
on a osé écrire qu'on pouvait être
offensif mais attention
on a déjà écrit dans l'histoire de
france qu'on pouvait être offensifs ça
c'est à la fin du 19e siècle qu'on avait
une superbe école de généraux qui se
présentait comme la doctrine offensive
le problème c'est quand est-ce qu'on a
attaqué au 20e siècle a fait début en
délit de gide ou non mais quand à ton
attaque et c'est à dire qu'on a écrit
des textes et on les a pas vraiment
appliquée aussi ou vraiment à un niveau
très moderato cantabile d'accord là on
est devant le même problème c'est à dire
que on n'a pas encore osé écrire il ya
la guerre de l'information par le
contenant et il ya la guerre de
l'information par le contenu celle dont
vous venez de parler
cette guerre de l'information par le
contenu moi je encore une fois
petite expérience personnelle j'ai eu
j'ai participé à un groupe de travail au
gdn quand alain juillet était haut
responsable à l'intelligence économique
et là je peux le revendique et j'avais
dit alain juillet ça serait c'est
vraiment important de faire un groupe de
travail dessus il l'a fait seule fois de
ma vie où j'ai eu une accréditation une
habilitation pardon et j'étais le seul
prix entre guillemets et on a sorti un
rapport classifié bien sûr une partie
est la conclusion du rapport c'est pas
classique si non on peut la donner
celui qui gagne c'est celui qui attaque
qui celui qui attaque
fermer le rapport il a terminé vous
savez que l'administration française a
un talent dans l'immobilier dans six
veuves dans l'archivage qui est
absolument nummi mental c'est dans un
placard qu'on ne trouvera plus d'accord
donc le le je pense que la photographie
était bonne les mois j'ai eu la bonne
surprise de voir les gens des services
spécialisés ou différentes
administrations d'état qui ont joué le
jeu et miel
d'abord de montrer des choses que
d'habitude il ne montrait pas je me
souviens d'un excellent rapport je vais
pas dire qu'il a fait mais sur
finmeccanica sur la stratégie italienne
très subtil pour piéger en fait
l'industrie de défense européenne ou le
ce qu'elle pouvait être joué sur un
rapport d'alliances avec les états unis
aident dans un dans un contexte que l'on
pouvait même pas imaginer c'est à dire
l'italie mais il n'y a pas d'état
italien si justement il y en avait un et
on le voyait courir dans le temps on le
voyait
innovant créatif
les gens qui restait en place à des
niveaux intermédiaires mais vraiment
avec une stratégie qui se déroulait une
stratégie avec des résultats ils ont mis
ce rapport là dans le tag génial génial
enfin un rapport comme ça et il y en a
eu d'autres du même type
la parole était libre au sgdn la parole
était libre ce jour là et ça faisait du
bien on a sorti ce rapport mais quand
les gens ont lu le rapport
qu'ils ont compris que en guerre de
l'information en as trop sur films etc
il faut être offensif
ils ont fermé le placard d'accord parce
que on retombe sur le problème qui va
prendre cette patate chaude
d'aucuns diraient ce bâton merdeux avec
une culture sous jacente dans certains
milieux pas de couilles pas d'
embrouille je sors les formules bien
connu à l'intérieur de l'appareil d'état
dans certains milieux donc qui va
prendre le risque qui va assumer la
logique sacrificielle qui va être
créatif créatif
pour pas créer une usine à gaz pour
parfaire les cellules li zhen pour paf
déclencher une guerre entre services
qui va faire ça
au civil
obligatoirement café winston churchill
au début de la seconde guerre mondiale
il a créé un ministère la guerre
économique il est allé chercher lui
conservateur des marxistes dans le camp
travailliste
des marxistes dans le camp travailliste
il a créé un est ce qui a fortement
déplu au mi6 et pièces déjà à l'époque
et est là quand on dit des guerres
intestines
ces redoutables
le ss pour flinguer la réputation du
vaisseau et le récupérer a quand même
envoyé à l'abattoir un réseau de
plusieurs centaines de résistants
français
là ça ne rigole plus les guerres
intestines d'accord mais heureusement
dans ce café cherche il y avait la
partie s'était pas encore astro sur fing
mais radio noir plus la partie
intoxication qui était gérée
effectivement par des gens aux profils
assez intéressant qui sortait de
l'ordinaire churchill avait ce courage
avait ce talent stratégique il n'était
pas hors sol wiston churchill il avait
les pieds sur le sol ils savaient très
bien qu'à la sortie de la guerre on
allait le foot dehors parce qu'on dit
jamais merci à quelqu'un qui vous rend
service c'est clair
mais il a assumé ok il a assumé
en france il faut quelqu'un qui assume
en agence et
sincèrement j'en sais
comment on fait pour éviter la
dislocation géopolitique mondiale quand
on voit que
l'europe se ce territoire d'amour et de
solidarité
onze vols les masques quand il ya une
épidémie on fait de la rétention
douanière
on laisse on laisse les italiens dans la
merde
c'est un peu chacun sont cuits du plan
tous
comment on fait pour éviter la
dislocation géopolitique de l'europe
une anecdote pour répondre à ça
au cours de ma vie par moments avec
d'autres je me suis auto missionné auto
missionné ça veut dire faire quelque
chose et personne ne vous a dit de le
faire je suis pas le seul à avoir fait
ça il ya des fonctionnaires français qui
ont passé leur temps à le faire et en
l'occurrence fusil pour saint louis en a
qui sont fait fusiller pour ça
c'était rappelez-vous le parlement
européen avait organisé un colloque sur
le système échelon et quelle ne fut pas
ma surprise qui m'invitent - chu
totalement incompétent sur tout ce qui
est technique interceptions informatique
mais il voulait pas du tout me faire
venir pour ça il voulait me faire venir
sur les questions déjà que vous venez
d'évoquer astres surfin' guerre de
l'information par le contenu etc donc je
suis intervenu hockey
et quelques mois plus tard
je suis invité par le faire face aux
shoots du land du bade wurtemberg alors
le faire face aux chocs du gang du
bade-würtemberg en mai en allemagne ça
veut dire que chaque land un système de
contre espionnage contrairement à la
france et pas un garage avec trois
bureaux et
remington non
un bâtiment consistant avec plusieurs
centaines de personnes travaillant dans
la réunion était assez drôle enfin assez
drôle
il était à peu près 8 ou 9 il y avait le
président du fer façon il y avait les
sept autres et j'étais moi et au
cas sublime à mes anciens il ya très
longtemps
qu'est ce qu'ils nous disent ils lui
disent écoutez en allemagne à deux
länder
qui sont
distants par rapport à l'emprise
américaine le bas du rhin mer et la
bavière bavière
il ya des restes des résistants
historique peut-être sous jacents et ils
nous disent mais au niveau fédéral
on peut rien faire
on était au tout début des années 2000
il ya 20 ans mais je note quand même qui
a us ce dialogue qui est quand même un
dialogue un peu particulier je ne
représentait rien d'accord
donc pour répondre à votre question
si on veut arriver à créer des choses
dans le cadre européen il va falloir
transgresser un certain nombre de
principes
il va falloir trouver d'autres chemins
et ses chemins là pourquoi ils sont
éventuellement
envisageable parce qu'il ya une sorte de
règle évidente c'est que
face à la chine face aux etats-unis et
aux autres
je reviens sur russie et éventuellement
des puissances du type hier en turquie
yacht qui ont leur propre dynamique
qu'est ce qu'un pays comme la france
peut faire
là c'est encore plus dur le scénario
d'accord donc il faut effectivement
contre vents et marées
créé et on sait que ça va demander là je
vais pas malheureusement réjouir les
gens pressés des siècles
créer une dynamique européenne et que
pour qu'elle commence à être créé c'est
pas simplement le film l'auberge
espagnole que beaucoup de jeunes ont
aimé c'est de l' aventure humaine c'est
des réseaux croisé particulier c'est un
combat comme
parce que là je vais pas la jouer à
l'envers mais si on fait un peu hameau
qui moi m'avait beaucoup impressionné du
rouge bien entendu un peu de syncrétisme
culture du combat française plus culture
du combat allemande plus culture du
combat on peut aligner comme ça d'autres
choses et qu'on commence à faire un
petit cocktail
bien parce que j'ai dit sur l'armée de
l'an 2
je pense qu'on va faire des choses assez
intéressantes
est-ce que vous ayez des sujets
à une question de hugh folk vous avez
publiquement soutenu emmanuel macron
pensez vous qu'il soit l'auteur des
enjeux
non je n'ai pas je n'ai pas publiquement
soutenu
parce que ça se saurait c'était quoi
c'était un peu de lèche ses comptes
n'ont même pas un non non non il ya une
position tactique précise
par rapport à macron
c'est un enjeu majeur qui est
c'est quoi la france
et éviter qu'un peuple bouffe l'autre
d'accord ça s'appelle le problème de
l'islam d'islamisation sociologique de
la france
ça c'est un front principal
parler parmi le ton
est là pourquoi
l'islamisation de la france
elles existent partiellement ici et là
elle n'est pas aussi importante qu'on ne
pourrait le croire parce que moi pour
l'instant en tout cas
j'estime que le principal bouclier réel
et sociologique c'est la société de
consommation qui pour l'instant
fonctionne d'accord mais jusqu'à quand
et oui il ya un problème à partir du
moment où des gens estiment que leur
religion c'est la meilleure il faut que
les autres la croatie non ce sont des
mécréants et des connards ça
personnellement moi c'est pas possible
c'est pas possible ce qui veut dire que
non
j'ai pas foutu macron mais sur un plan
précis je ne suis pas là dans la logique
du en même temps et que le principal
message que je voulais mon pas moi mais
lui faire parvenir c'est que la
philosophie ou la stratégie je pense
plus philosophique stratégie du en même
temps c'est un suicide point à la ligne
et que cette ligne de front elle est
absolument fondamental c'est à dire
qu'on ne doit en aucun cas baisser la
garde
comme nous l'avons trop souvent fait
à certains moments et je répète la
grande surprise ils appellent ça la
grande surprise c'est que finalement
pour l'instant dans dans le coffee d' il
n'y a pas eu l'explosion urbaine d'une
deuxième crise des banlieues ce qu'ils
appréhendaient pourquoi parce que je
pense pour deux raisons on speed shift
pardon pour ce pitch it que c'est pas ce
pitch it vous après vous appelez c'est
comme les pizzas arrivent vous avez
votre chute libre et la grève au speed
shift en fait pour une raison très
simple on laissait les économies
souterraines tranquille mais bien sûr
première chose du coup quand même ce
pitch it's a
peut-être
peut-être par d'autres circuit en
circuit court de légumes etc sans jouer
forcément les des rescapés de la
troisième vague mais non mais ce que je
veux dire sérieusement c'est que bien
sûr qu'ils ont ils ont été habiles dans
pas être enrayée courte mais en reine
longue en n'appliquant pas la loi
française d'ailleurs c'est à dire que
mon fils une amende à intel et à l'autre
on détourne le regard ça déjà c'est
c'est pas c'est pas simple à cheval non
c'est ce qui se passe quand on essaie un
peu trop mis tout haut abbas a posé un
problème surtout quand on essaie d'en
revenir dessus ça c'est vrai on en a pas
et est sacré sert d'un vrai problème ce
que je veux dire par là c'est que
pourquoi je dis que
la société de consommation est encore un
an par mais qui peut être préfet gilles
et c'est une digue qui peut se briser et
derrière effectivement à partir du
moment où il ya fusion entre la faim la
peur de la fin le non accès à société de
consommation et d religion conquérante
qui veulent se substituer à d'autres en
termes de système et pas simplement de
pratique là le problème est
excessivement sérieux et grave et il
faut le prendre à cette hauteur c'est la
seule raison pour laquelle
n'ont pas attendez macron tournant mais
parce qu'à un moment donné il ya eu une
réflexion au sein en marge d'un tout
petit groupe sur ce sujet mais que
malheureusement d aurélien taché et
d'autres
ont servi de plafond de verre pour que
la réflexion ne perce pas lé place on
est d'accord et qu'aujourd'hui on est
dans la situation suivante c'est qu'on
est au jour le jour on brûle des cierges
part dans les églises c'est à dire en
dix ans pour le vous que sadoul et
jusqu'aux présidentielles et qu'on n'est
pas cette charge la a porté sur les
épaules mais le problème c'est que cette
charge là et maintenant de nature
sociologique c'est un problème qu'il
faut regarder avec le maximum de
lucidité et en aucun cas considérer que
c'est un problème qu'il faut repousser
aux calendes grecques pour les
générations futures elle se démerde
rompt avec sa nou pour l'instant on
évite joue encore une parenthèse la
route de la soie vous avez un mois nous
dire de sucer de l'influencé un plomb un
très long terme de la chine
c'est une façon de faire miroiter des
contrats c'est une façon d'éviter de se
faire attraper sa flotte par la marine
américaine dont le collier de perles
sais c'est quoi alors là c'est là c'est
intéressant de faire un parallèle entre
le japon et la chine ce qui a planté le
japon au début des années 90 et on a
perdu de vue cela et c'est bien dommage
c'est que le japon a dit nous allons
faire un super projet qui s'appelle le
techno globalisme et le techno
globaliste la légitimité du projet
c'était dire il ya trop d'écart entre
les pays développés et ce qu'ils ne sont
pas il ya un enjeu majeur c'est la
recherche développement cet écart ne
cesse de s'agrandir pour résoudre ce
problème qu'est ce qu'on va faire on va
créer un système
informatique
pour stocker la connaissance et la
distribuer à fin je simplifie afin que
la concurrence la compétition elle se
déporte de l'amont vers l'aval
c'est-à-dire que la r&d ça doit être
déjà dans une vision où on aide les
audaces en sortir pour ne pas plonger
davantage
quand les américains ont vu ça ils ont
compris que
stockage développement informatique ça
allait être les japonais qu'ils aient
c'est pas possible ce n'était pas
admissible et sa maman tout petit niveau
je l' ai vécu dans une fenêtre de tir
qui était ledit edith cresson premier
ministre ou ce sujet a été évoqué où il
ya des notes qui ont été écrites par
philippe caduque par mois
pour bien mettre en avant le problème
que ça représentait le problème que ça
représentait
2020 et route de la soie
et le problème des chinois c'est
qu'effectivement
ils ont compris qu'il fallait surtout
pas arriver en offrant une solution
monde surtout dans le monde immatériel
avec tout ce qui a sur les regarder ce
qui se passe en ce moment sur way et sur
les aspects microprocesseurs et ses dons
qu'ils ont compris que ce n'est surtout
pas recommencer
comme les japonais l'avaient fait en
arrivant avec une légitimité on vous
aide
finalement les chinois ont fait linverse
il part de leur histoire il parle des
traces de leur histoire parce qu'ils ont
étudié aussi comment on a essayé à
certains moments de reconstituer des
traces marchande je me souviens une
époque en france il ya il ya des villes
qui ont fait cet effort là de traces
marchande portuaire pour aller vers
l'espagne par exemple et ils sont dix là
on a une légitimité entre guillemets
pacifique c'est à dire les routes de la
soie c'était du commerce d'accord on va
reprendre ce concept et on va refaire
n'ont peut-être un tout petit peu rêver
les gens et là je vois
résultats à l'école normale supérieure
de lyon
il ya des gens qui sont là dessus et qui
voudront à terme trouver du travail à
partir de ça et ces gens là
bien entendu ils ont compris que faut
pas critiquer la chine parce que sinon
c'est terminé ok donc on est déjà dans
de la retenue dans là une sorte de
compromission de deux futurs business
etc mais le problème des routes de la
soie
c'est que c'est les routes
et les routes c'est la conquête c'est
pas simplement les changes
et que en termes de concept là où il
commence à être pris à leur propre piège
c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait passer par
les routes et là on retombe dans les
problèmes de guerre économique si on
veut la jouer fine il faut que ça passe
dans les deux sens d'accord or quand on
commence à passer au scanner le bilan
des joint-venture
en chine
moi je suis allé deux fois au japon mon
premier signal dallaire c'est quand les
japonais ont dit mais on gagne pas de
fric en chine
ont fait bien pompé mai mais je dis
attendez vous gagnez pas d'argent c'est
pas possible vous y êtes vous êtes vous
il ya plein d'étudiants chinois là où
vous avez accueilli dans
à tokyo que l'état oui mais
on dépend on est obligé mais on qu'à une
pas vraiment d'âge
à okc ont donc le problème c'est le deal
des routes de la soie qui gagne quoi
est-ce qu'elle fonctionne dans les deux
sens si les routes de la soie elle
fonctionne que dans un sens
et bien c'est quoi c'est l'impérialisme
économique et résultat des courses c'est
bien ça va être la confrontation non pas
militaire faut le souhaiter mais y'aura
guerre économique du tampon pourquoi
parce que c'est trop gros parce que la
ficelle est trop grosse et parce qu'on
va pas avaler une couleuvre aussi grosse
donc une dernière question de la
communauté et puis après on va reprendre
d'autres lignes que pense-t-il du niveau
de l'intelligence économique française
et du renseignement
la pince tel assez forte pour anticiper
les possibles des routes notamment
chinoises et je reviens à ma question de
thaler qui anticipe le menace qui fait
des stratégies pour contrer ces menaces
théoriquement
il serait judicieux qu'au medef il ya
une vraie cellule stratégique sur sa non
mais je sais pas
ça tomberait sous le sens pourquoi je
dis ça parce que le patronat allemand le
patronat allemand
roux de bézieux qui parlait de tout à
l'heure mais le patronat allemand il l'a
une cellule stratégique sur sa
et une cellule stratégique qui est
absolument redoutable parce qu'il est
impossible là c'est le problème de
l'europe c'est comment on va essayer de
jouer à l'encontre de ce type de
contradictions nous on a pas six mais
des affaires internationales fait du bon
boulot ils ont ils ont observé des
choses intéressantes mais le vrai medef
le medef au sens
organique et j'ai envie de dire
je suis pas sûr que ce soit sa tasse de
thé moi j'en ai eu la démonstration un
jour ma vie des astronautes et se
détruisent le système social français
non c'est cette continuer à faire ce
qu'ils font depuis toujours je prends ce
moment le système tout sauf exemple là
parce que pour moi il était très
éclairant il ya il y avait les
universités d'été à jouy en josas au
siège sida chaussée un jour quelques
années j'y vais comme intervenants et
bien entendu la discussion commence sur
l'essai de travail et les taxes etc
enfin on connaît et moi je réoriente sur
les problèmes de guerre économique
je pense avoir donné assez d'arguments
pour que les patrons présentant
d'oreilles et là je sis à quoi les
patrons présents 10 sur ce sujet là il
nous faut une feuille de route du
politique
à
et là on est dans le problème français
pur et dur
pourquoi le patronat français n'auraient
pas comme le patronat allemand une
vision géo économique pourquoi
qu'est ce qui les en empêche
où est le problème
et ça là on met le doigt sur le
troisième grand défi on a parlé de la
pédagogie on a parlé de la lecture le
troisième grand défi c'est comment
sortir
de cette vision
totalement
ethnocentrée de notre tissu économique
c'est à dire comment on sort de ça
comment on retrouve des points de repère
qui ont existé le pire c'est qu'ils ont
existé dans le passé
le patronat français au milieu 19e
siècle il avait encore une idée de ce
qu'était la défense
d'un circuit marchand les problèmes de
douanes la manière dont les britanniques
étaient en train de complètement nous
déstabiliser en profitant de la vente a
justement de la restauration que les
troupes du roi d'angleterre avait aidé à
ramer aura de france au pouvoir donc
face à un prix c'est des concessions et
ça a été très très dur de revenir sur ce
type de concession
donc on a eu à un moment donné un
patronat qui avait une pensée très
sérieux sur voilà la réalité
de la confrontation les britanniques
sont en train de déborder complètement
par la lecture
adam smith
son livre
et on oublie de préciser qu'en lisant le
bouquin de dan smith
il a fini dans l'appareil de douane et
il est écrit très clairement il faut
ouvrir les frontières à condition que ça
ne desservent pas l'intérêt de l'art de
la couronne britannique
donc
c'est intéressant aussi ça de rentrer
dans cette matière là pour voir les
contradictions internes ce qui est d'y
pallier ce qui a été susurré du bout des
lèvres ce qui veut dire quoi ce qui veut
dire que le troisième défi porte sur
l'autonomie de pensée des acteurs
économiques comment vont-ils
éventuellement retrouver une autonomie
de pensée
ça c'est le défi le plus difficile
pourquoi parce que
parce qu'ils ont depuis la fin de la
seconde guerre mondiale
ils se sont installés dans la position
suivante la sécurité de la france en
gros c'est les états unis qui l'assurent
et nous laissez nous bosser dans notre
activité
et le reste c'est pas vraiment ce qui
nous intéresse et ça on a beaucoup
travaillé alléger sur cette question là
surtout sur la période gaulliste ou de
gaulle
n'a pas pu faire passer ses idées qui
avait des idées sur ce terrain là et il
s'est affrontée à qui il s'est effondré
à d ambroise roux enfin 4.20 très bien
expliqué dans son premier ouvrage sur
l'enjeu majeur de l'industrie
informatique et pas simplement faire de
l'industrie informatique national pour
avoir le joujou nationale non pour
qu'elle soit compétitive pour qu'elles
on a eu à chercher les parts de marché
parce que deux beaux l'avez compris ça
mais il s'est heurté à quoi ils se
heurtaient au fait que le patronat
français déjà formé toute une période
longue de la quatrième république
estimé que c'était plus la peine ce
n'était pas possible on était passé à
autre chose on avait créé dans notre adn
l'acceptation d'une dépendance
géopolitique et le prix à payer est ce
qui fait le problème du monde de
l'entreprise français idée là c'est à
dire que on est dans cette acceptation
bien entendu elle est pas claironner sur
tous les toits mais elle est vécue dans
le cher dans la chair
intime de cette entité là et le défi
c'est qu'il va falloir en sortir
il va falloir retrouver le chemin de
l'autonomie de pensée dans ce monde là
il ya quand même des pistes tout n'est
pas perdu mais c'est un sacré combat
on arrive à la fois notre interview est
ce que vous voyez des sujets que l'on va
pas aborder
oui aborder la whey alors vous allez
revenir pour la prochaine fois
trois bouquins conseillé à notre
communauté et un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
alors un bouquin
3 donc un premier bouquin qui pour moi
est fondamentale jan valtin sans patrie
ni frontières
pourquoi parce que alors si on veut voir
l' aventure humaine
dans toutes ses contradictions
dans l'histoire du komintern sur le
terrain allemand où on voit passer des
gens pour une fois michel aphatie
le héros des temps modernes alors pas de
bol c'est un héros commune ternie je
suis désolé pour ceux qui ont une crise
d'urticaire par rapport à mai michel à
vatine
par exemple donc c'est un livre qui se
lit très facilement ont bien entendu qui
a été après qui a donné lieu à beaucoup
de polémiques mais il ya des études qui
ont été faites d'ailleurs sur l'histoire
de l'auteur et tout ça on commence à y
voir clair livre absolument
génial d'accord
deuxième livre
david todd l'identité économique de la
france
qui est un peu laborieux au début parce
que c'est un essai académique mais qui
est absolument limpide
quand les deux tiers du livre
sur comment un pays comme nous perd sa
culture de ses côtés économique créé à
l'époque à la sortie des guerres
révolutionnaires
vraiment un livre absolument
génial moi je le considère comme le mien
le troisième livre et j'en parle souvent
à mes étudiants georges henri soutou
grand historien français l'histoire de
la guerre froide de la france car dans
ce livre la source et par un historien
qu'on peut pas traiter de cinglés il y a
écrit comment à la sortie de la seconde
guerre mondiale
l'ensemble du personnel politique
survivants
est allé voir les américains pour dire
aidez nous le prétexte c'était le risque
d'invasion en union soviétique mais qui
n'étaient pas vraies prétexte parce que
je ne vois pas comment l'union
soviétique aurait pu envahir l'europe de
l'ouest malgré la puissance de son armée
à ce moment là l'autre prétexte et elle
a remis une théorisation de l'allemagne
dire ça entre 45 47 c'était vraiment
être un grand visionnaire cas de le dire
mais la vraie réalité c'était que le pc
français était à 20 atteignez des 25 %
du corps électoral s'était le premier
parti de france et qui avaient un risque
qui se découpe de du chapeautage
soviétique pour suivre éventuellement sa
propre loi donc là même de gaulle c'est
ce que 10 août ou étaient pour dire
il faut cette protection et cette
protection c'est la dépendance des états
unis d'amérique c'est la construction de
l'europe c'est comme ça que ça s'est
fait et aujourd'hui il va falloir qu'on
retrouve enfin les chemins alors je vais
pas être sartrien de la liberté
un conseil pour les jeunes générations
qu'ils se dépêchent de se rendre compte
dans leur petit quotidien et j'ai eu
même petit quotidien que
que l' aventure humaine c'est de l'amour
du combat du sang et des larmes
christian bulot merci
[Musique]